[Musique]
Serge Zaka. Bonsoir.
Bonsoir.
Nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Syerview. Nous
sommes en direct. Est-ce que vous pouvez
vous présenter succintement ?
Alors, je suis Serge Zaka. Je suis un
passionné de méthodologie depuis que
j'ai l'âge de 9 ans. J'ai commencé à
chasser l'orage à l'âge de 13 ans. On
pourra revenir sur ce qui est la chasse
à l'orage tout à l'heure. Je suis
également passionné d'agriculture et
donc j'ai fait mes études en agriculture
tout en travaillant en tant
qu'autodidacte sur la météorologie. Puis
j'ai rejoint en fait mes deux ma passion
et mon métier sur une thèse en
agroclimatologie.
C'est l'étude qui étudie l'impact du
climat sur l'agriculture. Alors à
l'origine, je suis pas de France, je
suis du Liban, je suis né au Liban. Mes
parents ont fuit la guerre en France et
et j'ai fait mes études en France. C'est
là où j'ai grandi et c'est là où je
reste.
Ta mam. Euh donc tu es vous êtes docteur
en agroclimatologie.
Vous avez fait ça où ? Alors, j'ai fait
ma thèse à LINRA de l'usignan à côté de
Poitier et je travaillais sur l'impact
du changement climatique sur la
production prériale. La production
prériale, c'est le fourage. C'est la
prairie en fait ce qu'on donne à manger
aux animaux. Et de là, euh avec
l'expérimentation euh de fortes
températures, de sécheresse sur les
végétaux, j'ai appris en fait à relier
le climat sur les végétaux. Donc, j'ai
appris sur les plantes prériales, la
prairie, la fétuque, la luserne. Bon,
c'est c'est des termes assez techniques
mais c'est les mêmes principes pour le
blé, pour le maïs, pour la vigne, pour
les arbres. Et donc à la suite de cette
thèse là, je me suis renseigné pas mal
sur l'impact plus global sur
l'agriculture et aujourd'hui maintenant
je communique pas mal sur les réseaux
sociaux, notamment sur Twitter,
notamment sur LinkedIn, sur Blue Sky et
sur Facebook sur les impacts de la météo
sur notre quotidien, sur le quotidien
des agriculteurs, quels sont les
événements météorologiques qui impactent
l'agriculture, mais également les
impacts climatiques. On reverra
peut-être la différence entre météo et
climat. les impacts climatiques sur
l'agriculture. Donc c'est plus du long
terme des décisions politico sociales.
On est très content de vous avoir ce
soir parce que nous on s'intéresse aux
fondamentaux de soutenabilité de nos
sociétés thermoindustrielles et voire
occidentales et tout phénomène menaçant
les chaînes d'approvisionnement surtout
alimentaire nous inquiète.
Si on peut se tutoyer,
il y a pas de souci. Qu'est-ce que tu
peux nous dire sur les menaces que le
dérèglement climatique, le changement
climatique font peser à nos populations
dites thermoindustrielles, occidental,
civilisé, appelle ça comme tu veux.
Qu'est-ce qui se passe sur du court,
moyen et long terme quand il y a un
dérèglement du cycle des cultures, du
cycle des vermines ou autres parasites
si ça peut générer encore plus de
menaces ? Est-ce qu'il y a des choses
qui peuvent nous permettre de s'adapter
? Je t'écoute.
Alors pour répondre déjà globalement
avant d'entrer dans les détails, il faut
savoir que l'agriculture dépend
essentiellement du climat. Vous allez
pas avoir un Olivier à Oslo, vous aurez
plutôt des oliviers à Marseille. Vous
allez pas avoir des abricots à Bresse,
vous aurez des abricots du côté du
Rousillon. En fait, le climat, il
détermine l'aire de répartition des
espèces, il détermine aussi la façon de
les cultiver et il détermine en gros
toutes les filières agricoles. Toutes
les filières agricoles, c'est la
production en amont, en aval, également,
la consommation, les industries qui sont
placées sur ce territoire pour récupérer
cette production, pour la transformer,
pour la revendre. Donc quand un climat
évolue, forcément c'est également la
production qui évolue, c'est ce qui est
en amont pour la production et ce qui
est également en aval, donc les
industries agroalimentaires et la
consommation. Donc ça c'était pour le
global. Et quand on rentre dans les
détails en agroclimatologie, il y a cinq
principaux points qui impactent
l'agriculture.
Les premiers le premier point c'est le
gel tardif. Le gel tardif après
floraison.
En fait on a des problématiques
actuellement, c'est qu'on a la floraison
qui se décale dans le temps puisqu'il
fait plus doux en hiver. Donc les
végétaux se réveillent plus tôt, la
floraison est plus précoce et donc on
peut avoir des gels après cette
floraison au lieu d'avoir - 5°, on aura
plutôt -3, d'accord ? Parce qu'il fait
un peu plus chaud. Mais ceci dit, le
végétal va réagir puisqu'il y a du gel.
Et donc ça c'est le principal aspect
notamment pour la viticulture et
l'arbriculture. 4 milliards d'euros de
chiffre d'affaires en France en 2021.
C'est la plus grande catastrophe
agricole qu'on a pu observer depuis la
seconde guerre mondiale. C'était en 2021
dans un pays développé comme la France.
Je sais pas si vous vous rendez compte,
moins 4 milliards. Ensuite, premier
point donc le gel après floraison. Le
deuxième point c'est la sécheresse. La
sécheresse, on a à peu près la même
quantité d'eau qui va tomber sur une
année, sur un territoire donné en
France, un petit peu moins peut-être
dans le sud de la France. Mais cette
répartition est différente suivant les
saisons. Il y en a moins en été. C'est
le moment où il y a les principales
cultures. Et il fait plus chaud, s'il
fait plus chaud, l'évaporation et la
transpiration augmente. Donc les pertes
en eau des écosystèmes et donc on a des
sécheresses plus importantes.
D'ailleurs, 2022 et l'année où la
sécheresse a été le plus large et la
plus importante sur l'ensemble du
territoire, beaucoup plus qu'en 1976,
notre ancienne sécheresse de référence.
Donc la sécheresse, elle implique pas
mal de choses sur les cultures. Donc des
cultures qui se développent moins vite,
également des grains qui peuvent être
moins gros, qui se qui se remplissent
moins vite. Donc ça fait des pertes de
rendement. Le troisième point, ce sont
les canicules. Les canicules, bon, on
parle pas de canicules pour les les
végétaux, on parle plutôt de température
supraoptimale au-dessus de l'optimum de
croissance. C'est un ralentissement de
la croissance. voir quand on est trop
élevé que physiologiquement le végétal
ne peut pas résister, on a des brûlures
sur les feuilles, sur les grappes et
donc ça cause aussi des pertes de
rendement. Le 4è point, c'est la grêle.
Là pour la grêelle, on n pas forcément
de tendance à la hausse de des grélons.
C'est toujours un événement qui a
toujours concerné l'agriculture depuis
depuis depuis le début he la grêelle, on
n pas forcément de hausse de perte de
rendement, sauf en 2022. On a une année
assez exception. C'est quelle année ?
Euh c'est à peu près il y a plus de
10000 ans, il me semble. Après,
l'agriculture moderne, c'est vraiment à
peu près autour des 1945. C'est là où
c'est l'agriculture que j'étudie.
L'agriculture avant, c'était quelque
chose de complètement différent, ne
serait-ce que ce qu'on mangeait ou ce
qu'on produisait. Et juste le dernier
point, le 5e point, c'est le froid en
hiver. Puisque la plupart des personnes
n'en parlent pas, mais le froid en hiver
est nécessaire pour les végétaux pour
faire une bonne floraison. Et donc, s'il
ne fait pas suffisamment froid, on n pas
une bonne floraison et donc pas de bon
rendement. Ça s'appelle euh la
vernalisation. C'est quelque chose qu'on
en parle pas du tout et pourtant c'est
l'un des principales aspects d'impact du
changement climatique. Si
si tu m'autorises à faire un commentaire
et je parle sous ton contrôle, quand il
fait pas suffisamment froid en hiver, ça
ne tue pas toutes les vermines qui peut
y avoir dans le sol ou ailleurs. Et donc
on se retrouve à la sortie de l'hiver
avec plus de vermine. C'est vrai ? C'est
pas vrai ?
Tout à fait. C'est exactement vrai.
C'est bon, c'est un petit peu plus
compliqué que ça mais le la base est là.
En réalité, le gel en hiver est très
important pour un agriculteur. Un
agriculteur déjà lorsqu'il gèle en
hiver, il peut accéder à son champ parce
que le sol est plus solide en surface.
Premier point. Deuxième point, le gel en
hiver, bah c'est nécessaire pour les
végétaux pour le leur leur cumul de
vernalisation. La vernalisation, c'est
les besoins froids pour la floraison.
Deuxème point. Le troisème point, c'est
que le gel est aussi quelque chose et
c'est ça rejoint ce que tu viens de
dire, c'est quelque chose qui permet de
réguler ce que tu appelles la vermine,
mais moi je dirais plutôt les sports des
champignons, les champignons, les les
œufs d'ép les œufs d'épucerons et
cetera, les pathogènes. Et donc
lorsqu'il n'y a pas suffisamment de gel
et qu'on a de l'humidité et de la
fraîcheur en hiver, à l'arrivée du
printemps, il n'y a pas eu suffisamment
de mortalité hivernale. Et donc dès
qu'il y a de beaux jours qui arrivent,
directement les maladies peuvent se
développer. Et ça c'est une des
principales problématiques pour les
cultures sous par exemple, mais
également pour les vergers, pour la
vigne, on a eu pas mal de pression cette
année, mais plus globalement pour pour
vraiment toutes les cultures.
En terme d'anticipation, est-ce que tu
as des contacts avec les gouvernements ?
Est-ce que les gouvernements se
renseignent auprès d'agroclimatologues
concernant les menaces
à anticiper avec le le dérèglement
climatique, le changement climatique ?
Est-ce que
ils ont réellement pris conscience que
au Moyen-Âge, on avait de temps en temps
des gros problèmes au niveau des
culture, que ça a créé des famines, que
d'ailleurs Elign serait à la base de la
révolution française et est-ce que ils
sont conscients de notre vulnérabilité
dans notre chaîne d'approvisionnement
calorifique alimentaire ? Alors, c'est
vrai que depuis 1945, après la sortie de
la Seconde Guerre mondiale, les
gouvernements ont compris l'importance
de l'alimentation par rapport à la
stabilité aussi politique. C'est-à-dire
que lorsque le peuple n'a pas faim,
c'est un peu la puissance des frigos, on
appelle ça, lorsque le peuple n'a pas
faim, et ben il va avoir tendance à
moins faire la guerre, à moins être
violent. et et par conséquent, ils ont
investi énormément dans l'agriculture,
la chimie, la génétique, la
mécanisation, maintenant le numérique
avec des rendements qui étaient
fortement à la hausse depuis 1945. Il
faut savoir qu'en 1945, on avait à peu
près des rendements de 1 tonnes par
hectare pour le blé. Maintenant, on est
à peu près à 7 tonnes. Et c'est grâce à
ça qu'on est sorti
pour la même qualité protéinique et pour
la même qualité.
Non, pas pour les mêmes qualités. C'est
même pas les mêmes types de blé. Il y a
eu des évolutions génétiques extrêmement
importantes depuis. Les fruits que nous
avons maintenant ne ressemblent pas du
tout à ce que nous avons en 1945. qui a
eu beaucoup de sélection sur la beauté
aussi des fruits et la production un
petit peu moins sur la résistance aux
canicules au sécheresse. On on y
reviendra forcément. Euh donc depuis
1945 multiplié par 7 les rendements du
blé, c'est énorme et on peut remercier
d'ailleurs les acteurs qui ont travaillé
à ce sujet. Après, il y a certaines
limites au progrès. Au progrès
maintenant, on a des sols qui
s'affaiblissent, on peut avoir aussi des
problèmes environnementaux. On y
reviendra mais voilà, il faut trouver de
nouvelles alternatives maintenant pour
garder les rendements plutôt stables. De
toute façon, depuis les années et 2000,
le rendement bullet est stabilisé. du
fait des événements climatiques,
sécheresse notamment et fortes chaleur
pendant le remplissage du grain qui font
que les rements se stabilisent. Donc on
a une courbe comme ça en en production
de grain là en 2022, on était pas au
taquet taqué super corps battu.
Ah bah non.
Alors non euh ça dépend de quel grand tu
parles. Le blé on est à peu près autour
de la moyenne en 2022 parce que le blé
est favorisé par le CO2 dans le nord de
la France. Parce que le CO2 est un
fertilisant pour la photosynthèse. Il
faut le savoir.
Est-ce que le CO2 favorise la résistance
des plantes à des températures extrêmes
?
Du tout.
Non, il ne favorise pas. Il il accélère
la photosynthèse mais dans l'équation de
la photosynthèse, c'est CO2 + O lumière.
La lumière fait que apprendre à la
réaction, ça donne du sucre et de
l'oxygène pour qu'on respire. S'il y a
pas d'eau, il y a pas de photosynthèse.
Donc s'il peut y avoir plus de CO2 dans
l'atmosphère, s'il y a une sécheresse,
la plante ne va pas utiliser ce CO2.
Donc on a une distinction entre le nord
de la France où le blé est favorisé par
exemple par le CO2 et les sécheresses
sont plus tardifes dans la saison. Alors
que le sud de la France, il aura plutôt
des pertes de rendement. Dans le nord,
on aura des hausses. Dans le sud, on
aura des pertes avec des rendements all
jusqu'à - 15 % comme on a observé en
2022. Tu parlais de grain en 2022. Si je
prends par exemple le maïs grain, le
maïs grain c'est - 45 % - 54 % pardon de
rendement dans le sud de la France en
2022. C'est la Grèce, c'est le site,
c'est le site de l'État. Ce sont les
données officielles de l'État. Euh sur
le blé de la le blé dans le nord de la
France, on est entre + 4 et + 7 %.
Heureusement qu'il y a la plupart des
cultures de blé dans le nord. Dans le
sud, on est plutôt autour des - 15 %.
Donc - 54 % pour le maïs en 2022.
Sachant que d'après les scientifiques
qui travaillent sur le climat 2022 sera
une année normale en 2050. On peut se
poser la question de est-ce que la
production sera suffisamment rentable
pour l'agriculteur ? Et est-ce qu'elle
sera suffisante pour nourrir les animaux
? Et puis l'homme également d'ici 2050
si on continue à avoir le même système
agricole sans rien changer. C'est là où
on peut après dérouler bien sûr sur les
alternatives qui peuvent être bon
favorables dans un contexte de
changement climatique.
Un petit commentaire que je suis en
train de lire sur notre chat. J'ai eu
une deuxième floraison en octobre sur
mes cerisiers. C'est la première année
que je constate ceci. Quel impact sur
l'arbre ? On en reviendra après. Vivant
dans la région centre. Merci. On verra
ça. Euh j'ai j'ai donc pour revenir à la
perception de nous gouvernant hm
hm
est-ce que tu as eu des contacts avec
eux ? Est-ce que tes copains de prom eu
des contacts avec eux ? Est-ce que tu as
entendu parler que les agroclimatologues
étaient devenus la nouvelle denrée en
terme de prévision et d'anticipation
dans nos sociétés ? Oui ou non ?
Alors ça va être assez clair. Les
agroclimatologues ne sont pas assez
nombreux en France déjà pour pouvoir
avoir des contacts, on va dire
politiques. Moi, j'en ai. Je reviendrai
dessus.
Euh l'agroclimatologie n'est pas une
science qui s'apprend à l'école. Ça
n'existe pas une filière
d'agroclimatologue en France. Aussi
étonnant que ça puisse paraître dans un
contexte de docteur en agro
climatologie.
Je je suis docteur en écophysiologie.
C'est la l'étude de l'impact de
l'environnement sur la plante. Et dans
cette écophysiologie, il y a une branche
d'agroclimatologie, c'est l'impact du
climat sur l'agriculture. Je ne dis pas
que je suis docteur en écophysiologie
parce que ça veut rien dire pour le
grand public. Moi je suis très
spécialisé sur plutôt la partie météo
climat. Ce serait peut-être bien que tu
lees he pour qu'ils comprennent ce que
ça veut dire. Faut commencer la
sensibilisation.
Tout à fait. C'est c'est un peu aussi un
de mes rôles. En France, on a euh deux
ou trois agroclimatologues à Avignon.
Euh je leur dis bonjour d'ailleurs, ce
sont mes collègues.
Deux du côté de Dijon.
Euh on en a un ou deux du dans le
sud-ouest de la France et la plupart ne
parle pas sur les réseaux sociaux. Je
suis assez présent sur les réseaux
sociaux, même si on peut être peut-être
une petite dizaine en France, mais ce
n'est pas suffisant en réalité pour
faire face au changement climatique et
tous les défis qu'il y a dans toutes les
filières agricoles françaises. Et donc
ce qui s'est passé c'est qu'en 2021,
lorsqu'il y a eu le gel tardif, j'avais
commencé à prévoir cet épisode de gel 10
jours à l'avance pour prévenir les
agriculteurs parce que j'avais vu la
floraison dans les différents endroits
de France en me déplaçant et la descente
der fois dans les prévisions
météorologiques. Donc j'ai prévenu les
agriculteurs et à la suite de cette
catastrophe agricole nationale, la plus
grande, je rappelle, depuis 1945,
et bien c'est là où le ministre de
l'agriculture, Julien de Normandie à
l'époque m'a appelé et m'a dit "Je
découvre l'agroclimatologie
en 2021." Et depuis, on a beaucoup
progressé parce que l'agroclimatologie
est devenue un terme qu'on utilise
maintenant au ministère de l'agriculture
à tel point que maintenant on a des
projets d'agroclimatologie et je vais
d'ailleurs travailler avec le ministère
de l'agriculture. Je me suis associé à
la à l'entreprise CESCO pour travailler
avec le ministère de l'agriculture sur
la les futures biogéographies, l'airire
de répartition des espèces de nos
cultures en 2050 pour anticiper parce
que anticiper le changement climatique
au ministère de l'agriculture à
l'époque, c'était juste avoir une
nouvelle variété de maïs qui consommait
peut-être moins 3 % d'eau, une nouvelle
variété de blé. Le maïs, c'est en France
la production de maïs, c'est combien de
consommation d'eau ? Vous savez ? Alors
j'y reviendrai, je termine juste ce que
je disais et euh et alors moi je
voudrais aller plus loin leur dire queil
faut aussi créer nouvelles filières
agricoles et là on va travailler avec le
ministère sur ce sujet. Donc pour le
maïs, pour la consommation, c'est moi
qui te coupe là. Vas-y.
Euh construire ces nouvelles filières
pour pouvoir conseiller nos dirigeants,
nos gouvernants,
nos leaders charismatiques,
ça prend combien de temps ?
Alors ça va être assez simple. C'est 15
ans pour avoir un embryon et 30 ans pour
avoir une filière stable.
Tu te fous de moi là ?
Non, je me je me fous pas de toi parce
que j'ai vérifié ces chiffres là. Je
suis allé voir les producteurs de
noisettes, les producteurs de noix qui
se sont installés du côté du Périgor,
qui se sont installés dans le sud-ouest
de la France, qui ont promu promu
promeux cette nouvelle filière de noix.
Il leur a fallu 30 ans, ils m'ont dit,
pour arriver à à de l'exportation ou
alors même de de sortir de leur
territoire. 30 ans. 30 ans, ça veut dire
que si on travaille sur des filières
agricoles maintenant sur de nouvelles
filières, c'est en 2050 qu'on va avoir
une certaine un certain intérêt, on va
dire économique et un petit peu plus
national, voire même international. Euh
on est déjà en retard en gros pour pour
synthétiser. On est déjà en retard
puisque euh faire face au changement
climatique comme j'ai c'est pas trouver
juste de nouvelles variétés de blé ou
avoir des réserves de substitution en
eau ou travailler enfin les les
mégabassines euh ou avoir euh ou
travailler sur le sol, même si le sol
est extrêmement important. C'est aller
plus loin en réalité c'est développer
des nouvelles filières qui soient
adaptées à un climat futur parce que le
climat remontent et ça c'est le
principal aspect. On va pas se dire en
2050, je vais continuer à faire du maïs
dans le sud-ouest de la France. On a eu
- 54 % en 2022, sachant que ce sera un
climat moyen en 2050. C'est même pas
outre un aspect utilisation de l'eau,
outre un aspect environnemental et
fatigue des sols qu'on parle
régulièrement, c'est un aspect aussi
économique qui va supporter - 54 % tous
les ans en moyenne.
Et tu parles tu parles en terme
d'inflation ou tu parles en terme de
production
les producteurs qui vont pas pouvoir
avoir 100 % de leur récolte.
euh ils vont aussi faire répercuter les
prix,
c'est ça ? Ou alors importer Ou alors
importer ou alors ça aura des
conséquences sur la production animale
et sur tout ce qui se déroule après pour
le maïs.
C'est un facteur inflationniste énorme.
La le climat est le principal facteur
inflationniste avec bien sûr la guerre.
Le climat est le principal facteur qui
influe sur les les denrées en fait sur
le prix des denrées. Regarde par exemple
ce qui s'est passé au Canada il y a il
me semble 2 ans ou trois.
Alors tu parles de la moutarde du sirop
d'érable parce que le sirop d'érable ça
était très intéressant. Ça suffit ça
le sirop d'érable, j'ai pas suivi. Moi
j'ai suiv la su c'était c'était sympa
50°gr au Canada. Moi
c'était pas sympa pour eux.
Ouais 50°gr au Canada 50°gr au Canada et
il y a eu des problématiques sur la
moutarde parce qu'on a hyper spécialisé
le Canada dans la moutarde. La moutarde
de Dijon n'est pas de Dijon. C'est la
recette de Dijon. La moutarde vient du
Canada. C'est la recette de Dijon pour
laquelle on a le droit d'écrire moutarde
de Dijon. Mais elle vient du Canada en
majorité même si on essaie de la
réintroduire en France. Et bien 50° bah
forcément une baisse de rendement énorme
sur la moutarde avec cette hypers
spécialisation mondiale de la moutarde
au Canada. On est on pourra revenir sur
l'hyperspécialisation aussi et la
diversification nécessaire avec le
changement climatique. Et bien euh on a
eu des problématiques de de de moutarde
en France parce qu'on est les principals
consommateurs
principaux. Ah oui, les princip les
principaux pardon. Désolé, c'est mon
aspect libanais qui ressort de temps en
temps.
Non mais c'est pas bien de faire ça. Non
non non, je suis pas d'accord. Alors,
les principaux
les libanais parlent très très bien
français.
Les principaux euh les principaux
consommateurs de moutarde dans le monde,
forcément, on a eu des problématiques,
donc des prix ou desou même des des
ruptures de stock. Je prends l'exemple
notamment aussi de l'Espagne. L'Espagne
a eu une problématique de sécheresse
l'an dernier et une canicule à 38°gr en
plein milieu du mois d'avril pendant la
floraison des oliviers. Les oliviers
sont très sensibles pendant la floraison
au-dessus de 35. Donc on a perdu les
olives sans avoir sans avoir même vu les
olives puisque les fleurs sont tombées.
Donc - 50 % de production des olives. Et
cette hyperspécialisation c'est 50 % de
la production mondiale. Forcément les
prix explosent. Les prix explosent à
cause d'erreurs d'hyperspécialisation
qu'on a fait avant, à cause d'erreurs
aussi de monoculture qu'on a fait dans
certaines parties du monde. Et du coup
euh bah dès qu'il y a un événement
climatique, vu qu'on a mis tous les œufs
dans le même panier, le prix explose,
voire il y a même des ruptures. Vous
pouvez aller en Espagne et parler aux
Espagnols de l'huile d'olive maintenant,
ils vont vous dire "Mais qu'est-ce qui
se passe ? Quoi ? Qu'est-ce qui se passe
?" Voilà, donc oui, c'est un des
principales facteurs d'inflation de de
variation des prix, c'est le climat.
Alors, on va faire une expérience de
pensée toi et moi. Quand il y a une
sizigie
siigie, tu connais ?
Non.
Alignement des planètes.
Quand tu as l'alignement des planètes de
stress hydrique, canicule, de problèmes
d'approvisionnement
en fertilisant ou l'augmentation des
prix des fertilisants, augmentation des
prix de l'essence
et ben il y a une augmentation des prix
alimentaires. C'est normal. C'est la
goutte d'eau qui fait déborder le vase
le climat.
C'est normal quand déjà quand tu as une
association d'événements climatiques,
c'est pas additif, c'est multiplicatif.
Quand tu as une sécheresse et une
canicule et du vent, on appelle ça la
sécheresse éclaire. Ça dessèche
complètement les végétaux et donc ça
démultiplie les vapu transpiration et
donc ça te fait diminuer très fortement
tes rendements. 28 juin 2019, 46°gr dans
les ra 40 km/h de vent. Donc là, on a
une conjonction d'événements
météorologiques qui font qu'on a perdu
12 % de la production de vin en
seulement 4 heures sur le département.
Ensuite, quand on rajoute par-dessus le
prix des fertilisants, quand on rajoute
les événements, les contextes
climatiques et supraclimatiques, on va
dire qu'ils sont pas forcément
climatiques, les guerres par exemple
ou les sols détruit
ou les sols détruits, on pourra revenir
dessus. et bien euh et bien forcément
que les prix augmentent et ça il faut
comprendre, il faut que le consommateur
comprenne aussi que ce qui arrive dans
le supermarché, les denrées
alimentaires, c'est c'est arrivé aussi
avec la fatigue des agriculteurs et que
si les prix varient d'année en année et
queon peut pas avoir que des prix bas,
et bien c'est normal, c'est normal
d'avoir des prix bas, des prix qui
varient d'année en année et c'est normal
d'avoir des prix haut parce que
quand on veut rajouter sur le dos des
agriculteurs le respect du sol, qu'on
veut rajouter le respect de
l'environnement,
le respect du vivant,
le respect du vivant, de nouvelles
législations, des interdictions de
produits. Bien forcément, quand vous à
votre travail, quand on vous enlève des
moyens de travail et qu'on vous limite
votre façon de travailler, bah forcément
les prix vont augmenter, vous travaillez
de façon plus difficile, on va dire. Et
donc pour moi, c'est tout à fait normal
d'avoir les prix qui varient. Et après
c'est aussi au grand public, au
consommateur de comprendre que
l'alimentaire normalement dans une
société, on va dire
avant les années 2000, on avait quand
même une enveloppe alimentaire dans le
budget de la de de d'un ménage ou d'une
personne seule.
On avait un budget qui était beaucoup
plus élevé qui n'a fait que diminuer
diminuer diminuer parce qu'on produisait
à outrance avec de avec certainement une
fatigue des terres, une fatigue
environnementale, mais on peut plus
faire ça. Donc forcément les prix vont
réaugmenter, la pression climatique va
réaugmenter et éventuellement les les
guerres qui vont faire réaugmenter ces
prix. Donc le consommateur, il doit
comprendre aussi qu'acheter à manger,
c'est pas juste optionnel pour manger,
c'est aussi rémunérer l'agriculteur qui
doit faire face à ces événements
climatiques. L'un des principales
aspects pour faire face au changement
climatique, c'est l'argent. Il faut
avoir de l'argent pour faire face au
changement climatique, pour changer les
pratiques agricoles. Donc quand on va au
supermarché qu'on achète des des des
produits premier prix ou alors des des
choses ultra transformé en se disant je
vais manger rapidement ce soir, en fait,
on a perdu complètement notre façon de
s'alimenter. Il peuvent pas faire
autrement.
Alors, il y a des gens qui peuvent pas
faire autrement, bien sûr. Euh la
majorité de la population française, on
va dire 90 % peut s'alimenter
normalement. C'est jusqu'au détriment
d'autres loisirs, on a diminué notre
part alimentaire. Notre part alimentaire
diminue essentiellement parce qu'on est
devenu dans une société de
mensualisation, c'est-à-dire le forfait
téléphonique, Netflix, tout ça le et on
préfère
les impôts.
Bon, les impôts aussi qui que je
découvre également en ce moment de plus
en plus.
Ça c'est bien parce que tu gagnes de
l'argent. C'est parce que je suis en
train de créer ma nouvelle société
Agroclimat 2050 pour travailler sur
changement climatique. Donc je découvre
tout simplement les impôts de société.
Bon courage.
Merci. Je suis en plein dedans.
Oh pour expert comptable.
En fait même dans les populations en
réalité les plus pauvres françaises, moi
je viens du Liban hein. Les populations
les plus pauvres françaises sont les
populations moyennes, on va dire du
Liban. Euh au Liban, la part alimentaire
est quand même plus importante dans
l'achat et les loisirs sont moins
importants. Ils ont des loisirs
différents, ils sont pas à la maison en
train de s'ennuyer. Ils ont des loisirs
avec la famille, ils ont des loisirs qui
ne coûtent pas forcément énormément
d'argent. Donc
qui crée du lien
qui crée du lien. Voilà, on peut dire ça
comme ça. Donc il faudrait apprendre
dans l'avenir à refaire augmenter cette
part alimentaire dans notre budget
puisqu'il faut rémunérer les
agriculteurs et il faut faire face aussi
aux différences de prix. Donc c'est très
important réapprendre à cuisiner,
rééduquer nos enfants par rapport à la
cuisine, par rapport à comment on
produit et cetera. Donc il y a beaucoup
de choses encore à faire évoluer à ce
changement climatique.
Revenons revenons revenons sur l'aspect
politique de gestion. Hm hm.
Quand le ministre t'a appelé,
il était dans quel état ? Il t'a appelé
en direct ? C'est son cabinet qui t'a
appelé ? Il a eu ton numéro ? Quel type
de question il a eu tout de suite ?
Est-ce queil t'a pris en réunion entre
quatre yeux ? Est-ce qu'il avait besoin
d'un plan d'attaque ?
Alors euh j'ai eu un monsieur de
Normandie, Julien de Normandie qui était
très intéressé déjà ne serait-ce que par
la science agroclimatique. Donc il m'a
posé des question plutôt scientifique,
ce qui est parfois étonnant. Ça m'a un
peu dérouté euh de la part d'un
politique. Deux questions.
Euh comment ça se fait que la floraison
avance ?
Surface d'un nectar aussi non ?
Comment
quelle surface que superfic je pense qu'
qu'il connaît euh
toi ? On est en France ici.
Alors qu'est-ce qui s'est passé ?
Pourquoi on a eu cette catastrophe
agricole ? Pourtant, Méo France m'a dit
que il y avait régulièrement du gel en
avril. Pourquoi cette année a été
différente ? Pourquoi on a eu 4
milliards de pertes ? Quels végétaux
sont les plus concernés ? Et surtout
dans quelle région de France je dois
aller dans les mois à venir pour
rencontrer les agriculteurs qui ont eu
plus de paires de rendement ? Fais-moi
une cartographie des zones les plus
touchées. Donc il s'est beaucoup
intéressé, ce qui est pas le cas,
j'avoue, de tous les politiques, s'est
beaucoup intéressé à l'agroclimatologie
et à mon grand étonnement parce que
j'étais très loin aussi de la politique
à l'époque, à mon grand étonnement,
il m'a Oui, j'essaie. Il m'a invité
beaucoup dans les réunions.
On a fait un haathon avec le ministère
de l'agriculture pour réunir les données
météo et les données agro et voir
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire pour
travailler ensemble. Réunir
c'est public comme données, ça ?
Oui, c'est public. C'est c'est du
ministère. Et et là, il y a des appels
d'offres qui ont été faites sur lesquels
j'ai postulé. On on va travailler du
coup avec Cesco sur euh l'aire de
répartition des de production de fruits
et légumes. Donc les futures filières
françaises de fruits et légumes
2040 2050.
Ben c'est maintenant qu'il faut
réfléchir.
Oui. Non mais je suis d'accord. Faut
qu'on réfléchisse il y a 20 ans.
Alors oui oui oui mais c'est déjà bien
de commencer à y réfléchir parce que par
exemple si je prends l'exemple d'un
pommier d'un pommier d'un abricotier
quand tu plantes un arbre maintenant
c'est 30 ans de vie. Si tu te si tu te
merdes on va dire dans dans ta dans ta
plantation tuas tu as pas pris la bonne
variété ou la bonne espèce aujourd'hui
et ben ton arbre va mourir avant 2050.
Ça rejoint d'ailleurs la question sur la
floraison de de certains arbres. Et ben
c'est maintenant qu'il faut commencer à
réfléchir. Là c'est on a un one shot.
C'est one shot. Il faut planter vraiment
la bonne espèce, la bonne variété au bon
endroit. Donc il faut travailler dès
maintenant à le faire. Alors bien sûr,
je suis d'accord que c'était avant qu'il
fallait y réfléchir sous l'époque de
Chiraak déjà à réfléchir
avant Chirac.
Même avant Chiraak. Bon moi je je fais
sur Chirac parce que je suis assez jeune
et je connais pas ce qui s'est passé
avant.
34 ans.
Euh une année après l'âge du Christ,
c'est ça ?
Une année après l'âge du Christ et
d'ailleurs un peu plus bas que la
moyenne que tu as l'habitude
d'interviewer sur Sv. Bien ça. Ah,
j'ai regardé juste avant de venir.
Donc euh je crois que tu es le premier
libanais qu'on passe.
Et ben, j'espère que je serai pas le
dernier quand même.
T'inquiète pas, on a un gros carnet
d'adresse. Ah non, tu es le deuxème
libanais qu'on passe. Dis donc, tu es le
deuxème libanais. Et on a un gros carnet
d'adresse au Liban. Et ouais, on a plein
de copains là. Juste, je fais trop
clown.
Il t'a posé des questions sur la
production de bois. Tu sais là en ce
moment il y a une pénurie de logement,
les matières premières coûtent super
cher. Est-ce que tu les as senti
anticiper
les matériaux de construction de dans 15
ans ou de dans 10 ans ? Est-ce qu'il t'a
posé des questions sur les forêts de
pain ? Forcément sur les forêts de chaîn
de f l'agroclimatologie n'intagre pas
forcément la production de bois, c'est
surtout la production agricole mais on
va dire à manger alimentaire. Voilà
c'est une autre science la production de
bois. Alors,
ça s'appelle comment ? La
grosforesterie. Non, je me trompe
la gr Non, l'agroforesterie, c'est quand
on cultive sous les euh les c'est la
civiculture. Voilà. Bien vu.
Et bien euh on non on a pas parlé de
tout ça. Par contre, il y a de nouveaux
matériaux qui peuvent être intéressants,
notamment le chambre,
le lin
également euh qui sont de plus en plus
cultivés. En Normandie, on a beaucoup de
lin. Alors, il y a des problématiques
climatiques à voir si on va les cultiver
un petit peu plus au nord. Mais ceci
dit, il y a de nouvelles filières qu'il
faut absolument consolider pour les
matériaux d'avenir. Après, je ne connais
pas plus sur le bois.
Est-ce que les syndicats agricoles t'ont
contacté ?
Bien sûr.
Lesquels ?
La FNSEA. Tous. Tous. En priorité.
Alors,
c'est tous qui t'ont contacté parce que
tu es super bon dans ton domaine ou
parce qu'il faut une vision un petit peu
Johnson avec.
Ah non non non, c'est pas une vision
Johnson. même si effectivement j'ai 20
ou 30 ans moins queux, mais
en réalité la FNSA m'a contacté puisque
elle était dans des réunions avec Julien
Normandie à l'époque des soirées de gel.
Donc ils m'ont contacté pour déjà
comprendre ce qu'il s'est passé. Déjà
l'étape avant de de de prendre des
décisions, c'est de comprendre
l'événement scientifique qui s'est
passé. Et ensuite tous les syndicats euh
syndicaux syndicat syndicat agricoles
m'ont m'ont contacté puisque même le
conventionnel, le bio mais je parle à
tous les agriculteurs euh toutes les
agricultures d'ailleurs puisque'en
réalité quand il y a un gel sur un
abricotier qui a eu un pesticide avant
il y a de semaines ou qui en a jamais
eu, ça ne change rien. Euh et bien
l'agroclimatologie, ça concerne toutes
les formes d'agriculture. C'est pour ça
que je n'ai pas forcément d'affinité, on
va dire, avec d'autres formes, un ou
différents formes d'agriculture, sauf
peut-être l'agriculture de conservation
des sols ça stock un petit peu plus de
carbone. Euh l'agriculture de
conservation des sols, pour donner la
définition puisque j'ai balancé le mot,
c'est une agriculture en fait qui
respecte beaucoup plus le sol, qui remet
le sol au centre des interactions au
lieu que ce soit juste un support sur
lequel on apporte des produits à
l'origine de de de venant du pétrole, on
va dire.
Surtout
surtout oui et ben en fait on remet la
fer on redonne au sol la fertilité et on
reprend les services écosystémiques.
Service écosystémique c'est les services
que nous rend la nature pour produire.
Et ben l'agriculture de conservation de
sol, elle est basée sur trois principes
qui sont les principes, on va dire qui
qui favorisent qui qui qui sont les
meilleurs, on va dire pour le climat.
Donc c'est une agriculture qu'en général
les agroclimatologues apprécient.
L'agriculture de conservation des sols
se base sur le premier pilier qui est
qu'on travaille pas ou le moins possible
le sol. On le laisse vivre, on lui
laisse sa structure et on lui laisse
vraiment voilà sa vie. On va pas le
retourner le labourer. Le deuxième point
c'est que on va mettre des couverts
végétaux. Alors pour ceux qui
connaissent pas, les couverts végétaux
c'est quand on a de cultures A B. Quand
on récolte une culture et qu'on avant
qu'on plante la deuxième, le sol est nu.
Quand vous allez maintenant dans la
campagne généralement voyez des sols
marrons nus. et donc exposé au vent,
exposé à la pluie qui peuvent ruisseler,
qui peuvent s'échauffer avec le soleil,
qui perdent parfois des nutriments, qui
perdent de la vie. Et donc le fait de
mettre des cultures sur ces sols nus qui
des cultures qui vont économiquement ça
va leur servir à rien en en à court
terme, on va dire. Par contre, ça va
faire de la photosynthèse, donc ça
reprend du carbone. Ces cultures
ensuite, on les détruise, on les on les
détruit et on les met sur le sol. Ça va
fertiliser le sol et ce carbone va se
retrouver dégradé par les
micro-organismes dans le sol. la matière
organique du sol va remonter, la
fertilité du sol va remonter, sa
capacité à capter du carbone et à
stocker de l'eau important dans les cas
des sécheresses va augmenter de 5 à 10 %
à peu près. Donc 7 à 10 jours d'eau
supplémentaire pour les plantes. Voilà,
donc les les couverts végétaux sont très
importants. Et le dernier point, c'est
des rotations plus diversifiées, plus
longues. Dans un contexte de changement
climatique, la diversification est très
importante parce que si vous avez la
même plante sur le même territoire qui
est sensible à un événement climatique
et si l'événement climatique arrive, on
a des paires de rendement. Donc mettre
des œufs dans différents paniers, c'est
aussi garantir une stabilité des prix.
C'est ce qu'on disait tout à l'heure. Et
donc voilà, l'agriculture de
conservation des sols est quelque chose
que j'apprécie et qui n'est pas
forcément connue parce qu'on est
vraiment dans un débat en France
bioconventionnel.
ces deux agricultures et on oublie
vraiment l'agroforesterie, l'agriculture
de conservation des sols et plein
d'autres agricultures qui sont aussi
vertueuses, qui sont pas parfaites, il
n'existe pas d'agriculture parfaite mais
qu'il faut absolument considérer. Et en
tant qu'agroclimatologue, tout ce qui
stock du carbone, tout ce qui permet de
mieux stocker de l'eau, c'est ce que
bien sûr je promets.
J'aimerais qu'on qu'on élargisse notre
prisme de lecture et qu'on voit les
choses maintenant à l'échelle
continentale et mondiale. Hm hm.
Les risques du dérèglement climatique
sur les productions en Afrique, en Asie
du Sud-Est. Hm
hm.
Les avantages que le dérèglement
climatique pourrait proposer à certains
pays comme la Russie, les pays du Nord,
le Canada peut-être ? Hm
hm.
Qu'est-ce que tu peux nous dire
là-dessus ?
En fait, l'agroclimatologie, ça finit et
après je délègue à mes collègues, ça
finit sur la géopolitique mondiale de
l'alimentation. Ça va jusqu'à la
géopolitique mondiale de l'alimentation
puisque les zones climatiques, le climat
méditerranéen, les caractéristiques du
climat méditerranéen remontent, le
climat tempéré a tendance à remonter
aussi. Et donc les zones climatiques, ce
qu'on appelle la la biogéographie des
végétaux, l'air de répartition des
cultures évolue. Et vu que les
frontières bah ça concerne pas le climat
et bien bah ça traverse les frontières
et ça se décale vers le nord.
C'est-à-dire que dans les pays
développés, après je reviendrai au pays
africains plutôt, dans les pays
développés comme le blé, c'est l'exemple
le plus intéressant en ce moment, et
bien le blé, on va avoir des hausses de
rendement dans le nord de l'Europe.
Pourquoi ? Parce que déjà, il va faire
plus chaud. Donc la période de culture
s'allonge. Ensuite, il y a le CO2. Le
CO2 fertilise le blé. Et ensuite euh et
ben on a des filières qui peuvent se
structurer de plus en plus sur le blé
parce que ça fait un moment qu'ils
savent très bien que le blé va arriver
chez eux. La Russie, l'Ukraine, la
Pologne sont les futurs producteurs
mondiaux ou du moins européens de blé
avec le Canada également. Donc cette
géopolitique des frigos vides, on
appelle ça la géopolitique de
l'alimentation évolue parce que le sud
de l'Europe lui va être de plus en plus
dépendant des pays du nord de l'Europe
parce que lui il aura plus de
sécheresses donc plus en plus de
difficultés à produire ce blé notamment
autour de la zone méditerranéenne qui
est un hot spot du changement
climatique, une zone chaude là où le
climat a le plus évolué.
Je te coupe. Quand tu dis ils sont déjà
au courant, est-ce que tu as vu
bien sûr
des colloques, des réunions, des
publication ?
Alors, pas besoin de voir des
cololloques. J'en ai vu bien sûr, j'ai
vu des publications. Toutes les
publications indiquent que
ça où ça ?
Bah, n'importe quelle publication qui
parle de l'évolution du blé en Europe va
parler forcément de la Pologne, de la
Russie et de l'Ukraine. Mais partout ça
se parle. Et d'ailleurs, la Russie est
de temps en temps le premier producteur
mondial de blé alors qu'il ne l'était
pas avant. Il est en train de structurer
ses filières, la période de production
augmente, il a de nouvelles terres
agricoles qui dégèlent malheureusement.
Euh et donc euh
malheureusement
malheureusement parce que ça libère
aussi euh du méthane, voilà.
Et et d'autres choses.
Et après quand on labour ces terres-là,
on détruit complètement la vie, on
libère encore plus de de gaz à effet de
serre. Et bien euh il l'a compris
puisqu'il a conquéri peu à peu. Il est
devenu un des premiers
conquis, pardon. L'un des premiers
producteurs mondial de blé il y a une
année ou peut-être plusieurs années ces
der ces dernières années où la Russie
qui était pas du tout présent sur la
scène mondiale pour le blé devenu le
premier acteur du monde. Il a conquis
conquis des marchés au au nord de
l'Afrique qui peut
Comment dit conquis en libanais ?
Ah je sais même pas comment on le dit en
libanais.
Et euh et bien il a conquis des marchés
au nord de l'Afrique. Maintenant l'Égy
par exemple majoritairement lâché de
semblé en Russie alors qu'avant c'était
en Europe. Et peu à peu, il s'est
investi en fait dans cette géopolitique
mondiale du blé parce qu'il sait très
bien que le blé, c'est l'une des
principales espèces cultivées avec le
riz et le maïs suivant les régions du
monde, l'Asie et l'Amérique centrale.
Il a une militarisation de de
l'agriculture.
Une militarisation ? Oui.
Alors, je sais pas si je dirais ça comme
ça, mais il y a une politisation plutôt
de l'agriculture parce qu'il y a
plusieurs peurs en réalité. Il y a la
peur de la bombe nucléaire et la peur du
frigo vide.
Du
du frigo vide.
Tu connais le proverbe français ? Quand
il n'y a plus de foin dans les
rateliers, les chevaux se battent.
Bah voilà. Voilà. En fait, pour faire la
guerre à un pays, soit on le bombarde ou
soit on fait un blocus et on la fame
quand on la fame, ils ont déjà les
soldats en moins de force et la
population se tape entre elles et puis
les gens meurent. Il y a eu notamment
euh des blocus célèbres qui ont été
faits euh en Ukraine. L'holocauste, le
non, l'holocaust c'est
le lot de mort, pardon. Bon, c'est à peu
près la même base latine, on va dire.
Lolo de mort. Bon, qui est contesté,
ceci dit, par certains historiens et
d'autres qui affirment que c'était
volontaire, mais on on voit ces ces ces
problèmes politiques qui peuvent venir
en fait de des
mainant les blocus alimentaires, c'est
interdit hein. C'est je crois que
c'est censé être interdit,
c'est censé être interdit. À Gaza, il y
a eu un petit blocus élimentaire.
Alors, je suis pas sur place pour savoir
mais oui, effectivement ce que j'ai lu
dans la presse, après ce qu'on lit dans
la presse ne peut pas forcément toujours
être représentatif du territoire. Il y a
effectivement un un blocus, je sais pas
si c'est volontaire, involontaire, je
veux pas rentrer dans les détails, mais
c'est un des principales aspects aussi
pour faire tomber un pouvoir. Je
rappelle que la Révolution française
1789, elle est issue de mauvaise récolte
en 1988 et d'un orage en supercellulaire
qui a traversé la bosse en 1989,
grelligène qui a détruit les récoltes.
Et c'est comme ça qu'on a commencé avec
des mouvements de contestation qui sont
partis en fait des prix du pain. Les
événements révolution arabes aussi,
les révolutions arabes font partie des
prix du pain également. Bon, bien sûr,
il y avait des problématiques avant,
mais l'élément déclencheur en général,
c'est le prix de l'alimentation.
Juste avant, je te coupe, juste avant
l'augmentation du prix du pain et que il
y avait l'augmentation du prix du baril.
Effectivement, il y avait ça. Alors, je
je suis pas expert dans ça, mais ce
qu'on peut ce qu'il faut surtout dire,
c'est qu'il y a une sécheresse majeur en
Russie avec des températures audessus de
40°gr pendant plusieurs semaines. On se
rappelle de Moscou qui était
complètement envahi par la fumée et donc
ils ont fermé, ils ont gardé le blé pour
eux. En fait, c'est un terme, je me
rappelle plus du terme, mais ils ont
gardé le blé pour eux en Russie. Et donc
tous les pays arabes, bah forcément, vu
qu'ils étaient de plus en plus
dépendants de la Russie qui commençaient
à conquérir les marchés, et bien les
prix ont augmenté et ça a été l'élément
déclencheur pour les printemps Europe
qui ensuite se sont déroulés dans il y a
vraiment une puissance euh de
l'alimentation et l'agroclimatologie
permet en fait de savoir où est-ce qu'on
produira dans l'avenir et d'anticiper en
fait ces ces cette géopolitique mondiale
de l'alimentation. Donc si je te
comprends bien et si les politiques ont
bien compris leur boulot,
plus il y aura de mecs comme toi, moins
on sera obligé de du pognon dans
des armes.
Si je synthétise d'une façon
plutôt des arbres que la place des
armes. Effectivement,
on est d'accord.
Alors,
c'està-dire que quand tu anticipes tout
ça et que tu planifies correctement
comme un bon agriculteur, hm
hm.
Tu anticipes des mouvements sociaux, de
l'inflation.
Il faut avoir une vision long terme.
Est-ce que tu penses que
l'agroclimatologie peut,
je dirais une expression anglaise,
fiter, matcher,
s'accorder
avec la politique court termiste
électoraliste
de voter pour moi, je suis le président
du pouvoir d'achat.
Alors, clairement pas. Non, non, non.
Clairement pas. Euh là, c'est
l'agrométéorologie. L'agrométorologie,
c'est la météo sur l'agriculture. C'est
le court terme, action, décision,
terrain. Il y a du gel à venir.
Qu'est-ce que je dois faire sur le
terrain ? Je donne une enveloppe de 36
millions d'euros parce qu'il y a eu du
gel sur les pruneaux d'Agin. Je donne
une enveloppe de je ne sais combien de
millions d'euros pour euh pour des
aspects court terme. C'est ça qui est
électoraliste, c'est vraiment faire
plaisir sur le court terme et ne pas
travailler sur l'évolution de
l'agriculture à long terme. Ça c'est
l'agroclimatologie. L'agroclimatologie,
ça rentre pas forcément dans un temps
politique parce qu'une création de
filière prenant 15 à 30 ans, bah le
président, le le ministre qui se lance
là-dedans, il ne verra pas les effets
positifs pour son électorat. Il ne les
verra pas parce que ça sera dans 5 ou 6
quinquena dans très longtemps. Donc
c'est pas forcément des choses qu'il va
favoriser par rapport à au court terme
la grométéorologie. Euh et donc c'est
ça, c'est la principale problématique
qu'on a aussi avec le climat parce que
le climat les efforts qu'on fait
maintenant quand on voit les courbes et
bah il y a les efforts sont très
visibles à partir de 2050 ce qu'on fait
maintenant et et c'est ce temps
différent entre la politique et
l'agroclimatologie qui fait qu'il y a
une sission en fait de compréhension et
que la les principaux
aspects qui sont été développés pour
l'instant ces 30 dernières années, c'est
la génétique variété. Donc j'ai mon
maïs, toujours mon maïs mais qui
consomme - 3 % d'eau avec ma nouvelle
variété. J'ai les réserves de
substitution en eau ou dit mégabassin
qui permettent d'apporter de l'eau
rapidement une solution rapide même si
administrativement ça fait quand même
plus de 10 ans parfois qu'on travaille
dessus. Par contre
ça les mégabassines
bah je finis juste ça et je reviendrai
dessus. Par contre, les aspects très
long terme très long terme création de
filière, restructuration du sol, ça
prend 5 ans minimum pour restructurer un
sol, avoir un un minimum de de de de
restructuration. Donc ces aspects-là en
fait, on on les oublie complètement
aussi travailler sur la consommation
notamment la consommation de viande.
Faut pas juste réduire la production,
faut aussi travailler sur la
consommation pour qu'on en mange moins.
Donc voilà, il y a des aspects de long
terme qu'on oublie complètement. Je ne
sais pas si c'est volontaire. ou je ne
sais pas si c'est même par mes
connaissances de l'ag de
l'agroclimatologie et c'est ce que
j'essaie d'apporter. Ceci dit, il y a
quand même eu des progrès au ministère
parce que maintenant l'agroclimatologie
on en parle et ces aspects long terme,
ils sont introduits dans les dernières
études de de française. Donc voilà, je
suis peut-être naïf, peut-être qu'il
n'avait pas connaissance de tout ça,
mais euh mais maintenant on a quand même
quelques progrès. Maintenant, il faut
passer de l'étude au terrain et en terme
politique à voir ce que ça va donner. Je
peux répondre à la question des
mégabassines ou des réserves de si tu
veux comment
? Fais-toi plaisir.
Alors, tu as fait une très grave erreur
en disant est-ce que oui ou non tu es
contre.
J'ai dit contre.
Pour ou contre, c'est très binaire. Et
en fait en agriculture la les
problématiques qu'on a dépendent des
sols, des agricultures avec un s des
hommes aussi parce que ce sont les
hommes qui font l'agriculture des
différents types de nafréatique, des
différents types de sol, des différents
types de production. En fait, on ne peut
pas être pour ou contre.
une évolution sur l'agriculture parce
qu'elle peut être intéressante dans un
territoire comme elle ne peut pas du
tout l'être dans l'autre. sur les
réserves de substitution ou dites
mégabassine. Et bien en réalité dans
certaines régions notamment le sud-ouest
de la France, ça peut être très
intéressant de faire ce qu'on appelle
des retenues collinaires. On retient
l'eau qui descend des montagnes. On
laisse bien sûr filer pour la continuité
écologique mais on peut la retenir pour
les feux de forêt, parfois pour le
tourisme mais également pour
l'agriculture. Du côté de Saint-Soline,
on a tendance à prendre plutôt l'eau des
nafréatique, la mettre en surface. Bon,
il y a de l'évaporation, encore des
études à faire pour savoir combien
s'évapore, mais ça permet de substituer
l'eau qu'on récupérit déjà des neuf
ratiques, mais chacun dans dans son
petit coin récupérer l'eau pour rier. Et
là, on centralise
et on peut bien taxer en même temps.
Et on peut taxer, on peut vérifier, on
peut faire tout ce qu'on veut. Par
contre, il y a quelque chose de très
important et là c'est mon rôle là de
savoir où on met les bassines, c'est le
rôle des hydrogéologues. Par contre,
c'est ce qui se passe après qui
m'importe. Si par exemple on on met une
mégabassine, une réserve deion, une
retenue d'eau et cetera et cetera sur un
territoire, mais qu'on ne fait pas
évoluer l'agriculture en parallèle. Si
on fait pas évoluer l'agriculture en
parallèle, ça s'appelle une
maladaptation. C'est comme si vous
mettez la clime dans un bâtiment qui
n'est pas isolé. En gros, ça vous donne
une sensation d'amélioration dans les
années à venir, mais le changement
climatique avançant, il vous faudra une
deuxième mégabassine pour faire face au
changement climatique, vu que
l'agriculture n'aura pas évolué. Faire
évoluer l'agriculture, c'est que stocker
de l'eau également, mais faire diminuer
la consommation de l'eau. Là, c'est
combo gagnant, c'est-à-dire euh soit des
nouvelles variétés de maïs dans les
territoires qui pourront les accueillir,
soit changer complètement de culture,
réduire le maïs, mettre plutôt du
poischiche, du sorgot, d'autres cultures
qui vont pousser sur la même période. Le
tournesol également consomme un peu
moins d'eau. Voilà. Donc c'est important
de faire évoluer l'agriculture à la fois
de façon technologique, à la fois de
façon agronomique, donc le les le bon
sens paysan à la fois sur le sol, à la
fois sur la biodiversité et de remettre
de la vie dans ce sol pour stocker cette
eau là qu'on apportera par irrigation.
Donc il faut le combo gagnant. Tout est
complémentaire en agriculture. Toutes
les solutions sont complémentaires.
Alors bien sûr, il faut savoir aussi
étudier en amont si cette mégabassine et
cette ou cette réserve de institution
est intéressante sur un territoire ou
non. Il y a certains territoires où elle
ne le sera pas.
Revenons sur la géopolitique de
l'alimentation.
Quand tu vois certains pays asiatiques,
l'Inde mettent des restrictions à
l'exportation du riz, tu lis ça comment
? Alors, il y a eu des restrictions à
l'exportation du riz à cause
d'événements climatiques, il me semble.
Il me semble. Après, j'ai pas étudié le
cas spécifique de l'Inde. Peut-être que
je dis des bêtises. Moi, ça me fait un
petit peu peur. Moi, ça me fait un petit
peu peur parce qu'il y a des il y a des
pays qui dépendent de l'exportation.
Chez nous,
l'Égypte, non,
je sais pas leel quel pays dépend de
l'Inde. En tout cas, je connais chez
nous, on a beaucoup l'Afrique du Nord
par rapport au blé également. Et donc en
fait c'est c'est euh
c'est se priver en fait les autres pays
de notre production. Et c'est simplement
que climatiquement parlant, le blé est
plus rentable à produire dans dans les
pays tempérés que dans les pays
nord-africains euh où chez chez les
nord-africains, il y a d'autres cultures
qui sont plus rentables à dat qu'on ne
va pas cultiver en France. Donc chacun
climatiquement parlant, on est obligé de
répartir comme ça la banane plutôt dans
les antilles. On va pas la cultiver à
Paris.
Et bien donc on a des échanges
d'interaux qui se mettent en place mais
la problématique c'est pas les échanges
entre eux parce que ça c'est il y a pu
avoir de l'entrée d'entreprise quand il
y a des problème. La problématique c'est
l'hyperspécialisation.
C'est l'hyperspécialisation que le riz
est essentiellement produit en Asie du
Sud-Est. On en a beaucoup moins
maintenant en Camarg. C'est
l'hyperspécialisation que le blé est
produit dans une certaine partie de
l'Europe. Quand on subit des sécheresses
dessus, on a une baisse de production du
blé. C'est l'hypécialisation de l'huile
d'olive en Espagne, c'est
l'hyperspécialisation du Canada avec la
moutarde. Et en fait ce qu'il faudrait
pour faire face, c'est pas d'arrêter les
échanges internationaux parce que ils
sont nécessaires pour avoir une
diversité quand même agricole. On pourra
pas produire tout dans certains climats.
Donc la souveraineté alimentaire, c'est
un peu une illusion. On peut pas se
renfermer sur nous-même parce qu'on
pourra pas tout produire.
Et bien il faut garantir c'est une
logique quand même d'échanges
internationaux mais éviter les
hyperspécialisations, les monocultures
et diversifier ces cultures dans le
monde pour pas mettre les eaux dans le
même panier. Dès qu'il y a un événement
climatique par exemple sur le riz en
Inde et bah tout de suite l'Inde doit
nourrir sa population, il ne peut plus
exporter et tous les autres pays qui en
dépend bah il se retrouve sans sans
forcément la production avec des prix
qui augmentent sur les marchés mondiaux
parce qu'un pays qui ne déverse pas sur
les marchés mondiaux ce sont des denri
en moins et donc quand il y a des denri
en moins, les prix vont forcément
mécaniquement augmenter. Est-ce que
l'agroclimatologie s'intéresse au fait
que il y a certains sols en France ou
ailleurs
proche de la mer qui risque de voir leur
niveau de salinité augmenter ?
Je viens de faire un post sur Twitter il
y a 2 heures à ce sujet.
Euh
j'ai pas vu ton post Twitter.
Ah bah bah ça tombe très bien que tu en
parles parce que j'ai regardé ça tout à
l'heure dans le train en venant. Je
c'est quelque chose que j'avais pas
encore forcément beaucoup regardé mais
effectivement quand on regarde notamment
du côté du entre Calaisy et Dunkerk
Dunkerk Dunkerk quand on regarde du côté
du Marotvin, quand on regarde du Maret
Breton, quand on regarde surtout chez
moi du côté de la Camargue
et bien en réalité on la mer monte, il y
a deux aspects. la mermond donc elle
l'engloutit des terres mais ça l'homme
peut mettre des barrières soit végétales
soit des digues jusqu'à un certain point
cependant il y a autre chose c'est que à
l'intérieur même de la terre en sous-sol
il peut y avoir l'entrée
par par capillarité ou même dans les
napréatiques ou les les réseaux d'eau
souterrain il peut y avoir l'entrée de
sel et le sel sur un sol c'est bah c'est
le pire qu'on puisse trouver ça tue
complètement la vie du sol et là il ne
peut plus être cultivé donc c'est un sur
certaines régions de France comme Ça, il
y a même aussi du côté du côtentin, mais
on va perdre des terres agricoles avec
la remontée des pardon des de la mer.
Surface surfaces.
Alors, c'est plusieurs centaines de
milliers d'hectares.
J'ai regardé ça juste avant. J'aurais
pas pu répondre à la question il y a 3h.
Maintenant, j'ai regardé ça. Donc,
plusieurs centaines de milliers d'états.
Ça paraît dérisoire par rapport à la
France, mais si on perd des terres
agricoles, on perd aussi des commerces,
on perd aussi des structures
agroalimentaires, des agriculteurs. Déjà
que on est en diminution. Donc forcément
ces gens-là vont partir. Donc des
déprises agricoles, des déprises aussi
euh rurales qu'on pourra constater sur
ces territoires. Donc c'est plus en fait
qu'une perte de terre agricole, c'est
car une perte d'économie. Alors ceci
dit, au niveau français, ça représente
peut-être 1 % des terres agricoles,
peut-être moins. C'est pas énorme en
réalité. Euh mais euh bon, après il
faudra parler quand même de l'état des
terres aussi euh des sols dans les
autres régions euh de de France
et du monde.
Et du monde. Alors oui, j'ai parlé de la
France. Alors, j'ai pas regardé partout
au niveau du monde, mais il y a
énormément de deltas, notamment pour le
riz qui vont être Oui. qui vont la mer
va s'aliniser et ce celle-là va rendre
ces terres incultivable.
C'est pas forcément énormément le cas en
France, même s'il y a quand même des
régions. Par contre, sur le monde, je ne
pourrais pas répondre puisque j'ai pas
encore regardé, j'avais commencé à
étudier surtout l'aspect français mais
j'ai pas encore regardé sur les autres
régions du monde.
Je te pose une autre question alors
c'est peut-être pas dans ton domaine de
compétence. Qu'est-ce que tu penses de
la spéculation alimentaire ? De la
spéculation sur les denrées alimentaires
?
Alors, c'est pas dans mon domaine de
compétence, mais vu de l'extérieur, je
peux quand même pororter une réponse,
c'est que ça me paraît quand même
curieux. Enfin, moi je trouve ça un peu
aberrant de de faire la spéculation
alimentaire parce que ça peut provoquer
euh, on va dire pas forcément des
famines, mais de d'une difficulté
d'accès au marché international pour les
pays qui ne peuvent pas se fournir sur
le marché international. Donc cette
spéculation, moi je la trouve ça
curieuse et je l'ai découvert il y a pas
très longtemps parce que vous savez en
tant que scientifique, j'étais très très
dans mon domaine et j'ai découvert ça
beaucoup avec la guerre en Ukraine et
ces prix qui évoluent et certains pays
après sont mis de côté et ne peuvent pas
accéder à ces derurs alimentaires. Donc
ça ne concerne pas que le climat là,
c'est pas que le climat qui fait évoluer
les prix, c'est aussi le prix des
matières premières, c'est aussi les
problématiques de de guerre qu'on peut
avoir.
Tu as lu le rapport du JC ? Alors si
quelqu'un vous dit qu'il a lu
entièrement le rapport du JAC, c'est
qu'il m parce que le rapport du JAC, il
fait des milliers de pages. Moi, j'ai lu
les parties qui m'intéresse et surtout
je connais le contrepché.
Moi, j'en connais une.
Ah oui,
Valérie Maçon Delmotte.
Ah bah peut-être oui. Valérie Maçon
Delmot qui qui a lu l'ensemble du
rapport de JX. C'est très bien. Alors
alors pour ma part je je accès
Jeanel
sûrement j'ai accès au rapport du J et
en fait je lis les les paragraphes qui
m'intéressent et les chapitres qui
m'intéressent. J'ai notamment lu le
chapitre sur l'Afrique et la production
alimentaire et les difficultés de
production alimentaire. J'ai notamment
lu les aspects européens également sur
la production alimentaire, sur
l'évolution de la phénologie des
végétaux et j'ai appris quand même pas
mal de choses mais il y a des choses qui
ont été confirmées, il y a des choses
qui ont été qui qui que que j'ai appris
notamment par rapport au cas de
l'Afrique. On a pas parlé de l'Afrique
et tout à l'heure tu l'avais abordé.
L'Afrique, il y a une difficulté qui est
supplémentaire par rapport au climat,
c'est qu'ils ont pas forcément des
filières puissantes ou des agricultures
puissantes pour faire face aux
événements climatiques. C'est une
agriculture qui est très familiale, très
rurale et dont le PIB de chaque pays
dépend encore beaucoup, enfin énormément
de l'agriculture. Certes, ça diminue
mais certains pays dépendent énormément
de l'agriculture. Et donc en fait quand
ils ont des événements climatiques qui
arrivent
de subsistence,
c'est ça, c'est une agriculture de
subsistence, c'est-à-dire qui qui moi
j'appelle ça familial pour que ça soit
plus compréhensible, c'est que ils se
nourrissent essentiellement aussi de ce
qu'ils produisent et après ils peuvent
vendre sur le marché les le surplus. Et
bien cette agriculture là est très
sensible au changement climatique parce
qu'elle n'a pas les bases suffisantes
pour y faire face. Elle n'a pas de
génétique, on va dire de de génétique
résistante à la sécheresse conicule
comme on peut la voir dans certains
pays. Elle n'a pas aussi d'échanges
internationaux si jamais il y a une
baisse importante de la production
alimentaire, on achète d'un autre pays
pour compenser. Elle n'aura pas
forcément les moyens. C'est une
agriculture qui n'a pas forcément les
connaissances agronomiques puisque les
agriculteurs ou les agricultrices qui
sont présentes sur place n'ont pas
forcément une formation agricole. Ce
sont des des traditions ancestrales qui
se transmettent. C'est pas forcément les
plus adéquates au changement climatique.
Et ce sont des régions qui sont très
concernées par le changement climatique
puisqu'ils sont très dépendantes des
moussons donc de l'arrivée de la saison
des pluies qui peut être décalée et
quand elle est décalée, ça peut
provoquer des choses extrêmement
importantes en perte de rendement ou en
excès d'eau comme on a pu le voir ces
derniers temps sur la corne africaine.
Donc c'est une agriculture qui est très
difficilement
qui qui fait face difficilement au
changement climatique, contrairement à
nous pays européens où on a quand même
des rendements qui sont beaucoup plus
hauts même quand on a un événement
climatique important. Et donc en fait la
la l'Afrique déjà pour faire face au
changement climatique, c'est pas juste
ce que j'ai dit, faire des réserves de
substitution, travailler sur les
variétés, c'est structurer la filière.
Déjà, il faut structurer la filière
agricole bien sûr en respectant aussi
les traditions locales. On va pas
arriver avec nos nos traditions
européennes et leur dire vous faites ça,
vous faites vous faites ça. Il faut
respecter quand même les cultures
locales. Mais structurer la filière pour
la rendre déjà économiquement plus forte
pour faire face aux événements
climatiques. C'est le premier point. Et
puis ensuite, on peut travailler sur sur
l'amélioration sûrement génétique des
des espèces présentes sur place.
L'amélioration alors pour le sol, ça va,
ils sont ils sont même mieux que nous.
Euh et et sur d'autres aspects, il y a
des améliorations encore à faire pour
déjà faire face au changement
climatique.
Donc pour revenir au rapport du GC, hm
hm euh euh quand tu vois l'extrapolation
de du réchauffement climatique, des
zones qui vont être touchées
avec un taux d'humidité très important,
quand il y a une augmentation des
températures, avec un taux d'humidité
très important, ça devient létal. Tout à
fait.
Il y a des zones qui produisent
énormément à l'heure actuelle qui vont
se retrouver euh avec une létalité
augmentée.
Comment toi en tant que agroclimatologue
tu vois les choses évoluer ? Est-ce que
tu vois un transfert, une translation
des zones agricoles suivant le
réchauffement climatique
avec bien entendu les populations qui
suivent cette translation
où tu vois les choses différemment avec
des politiques pas prêts à s'adapter qui
mettent trop longtemps à s'adapter avec
des murs qui se construisent avec des
gens qui sont bloqués. Comment ça se
passe ? Est-ce que tu le vois plutôt
coopératif ou chacun son fut et Dieu
pour tous ?
Alors pour l'instant, je le vois plutôt
coopératif parce qu'on a pas eu par
exemple en Espagne, on a eu moins 80 %
de rendement pour certaines régions en
blé mais ils sont pas morts de faim donc
il y a plutôt une coopération. Euh
cependant
ils ont les souissons là-bas hein.
Oui ils ont beaucoup de de bonnes choses
et je prendrai le cas de l'Espagne pour
parler de de ce que tu viens de de
mentionner. Euh et pour l'instant je
vois je vois une certaine coopération.
Alors on est dans l'Union européenne, on
a quand même une coopération. C'est
peut-être pas le cas. Je faudrais
vérifier dans les autres pays motoris à
te titiller un peu plus là. Vas-y,
vas-y.
Alors, tu parles de coopération Union de
façon Union européenne. Est-ce que tu as
vu comment on a coopéré au début du
Covid
avec les masques sur les tarmac, avec
les mecs qui se mettaient un petit peu
du genre "Tu décolles pas, je suis
service des douanes, tu comprends, c'est
un truc pour la sécurité nationale, tu
décolles pas avec les masques." Alors
que c'était des masques pour nos copains
italiens qui étaient
en en début d'épilémie en en Italie du
Nord et que il fallait quand même
coopérer. Donc moi, je me dis bon,
imagine-toi, on a une un alignement des
planètes, une sie parfaite entre un
orage supercellulaire puis ensuite un
coup de froid, un coup de chaud, ensuite
les sauterelles d'Égypte, ce que tu veux
du sable venant du Sahara où je t'en
passé des meilleurs. Est-ce que tu vois
la coopération européenne fonctionner ?
Alors, c'est un peu compliqué pour moi
de répondre à cette question. Faut
savoir que le Covid a été un choc
inattendu, rapide et qui a concerné le
monde entier. Donc on a
Attends, attends, attends, attends,
attends. Un choc inattendu de quoi ?
On a eu des on a eu quand même des plans
avec l'anticipation de des stocks de des
répétitions de C'est effectivement
discutable. Mais euh mais ceci dit euh
il y a il y a 10 ans, vous m'aurez dit
il y aurait une pandémie, j'aurais dit
bon peut-être pas ou je sais pas. Mais
c'est quelque chose de rapide, on va
dire. C'est la rapidité de l'arrivée de
de cette pandémie qui a fait qu'on a eu
des des comportements très égoïstes. En
en agroclimatologie, je peut-être être
un petit peu plus optimiste que toi. Je
suis ni pessimiste ni optimiste.
C'est c'est qu'on voit les choses
arriver quand même progressivement
progressivement et qu'on a peut-être le
temps et j'espère qu'on aura le temps et
j'espère que les politiques vont réagir.
On aura peut-être le temps d'essayer de
trouver quand même une coopération
internationale entre l'évolution des
biogéographies. Pour l'instant pour te
dire franchement en Europe on en discute
même pas c'est chacun son pays fait son
petit truc dans son coin sur l'évolution
du climat et l'agriculture. Mais on n
pas parlé de la future ère de
répartition de la better de la pomme de
terre qui remonte vers le nord de
l'abricot de l'olive du blé. Enfin ça on
en parle pas dans les discussions
européennes et j'espère que vont
arriver. Pour l'instant dans le climat
actuel euh on a quand même des
coopérations. Par contre, si on ne
s'adapte pas dans l'avenir, si on ne
s'adapte pas sur toutes les pratiques
agroclimatiques que que j'ai énoncé,
entre autres, il y en a d'autres encore.
Si on se renferme sur soi-même, c'est la
plus mauvaise idée qu'on puisse faire.
Euh ça ne veut pas garantir que
maintenant une coopération, mais ça ne
veut pas garantir que dans l'avenir on a
euh des embargots, on appelle ça des
fermetures de frontière qu'on ne qu'on
ne vend plus nos produits euh à
l'étranger. Donc pour moi, euh l'une des
principales aussi aspects pour lutter
contre le changement climatique, c'est
de euh de la coopération entre les
différents pays.
Alors, tu m'avais posé des questions
avant sur l'humidité de l'air et puis
sur les zones qui sont forcément avec
l'augmentation de la température.
C'est ça. Alors, on appelle ça l'umidex
pour l'homme.
Le corps humain ne ressent pas la
température, il ressent la température
et l'humidité. Si vous faites un
barbecue avec vos amis, il fait 32° et
10 % d'humidité, tout se passe bien.
S'il fait 32°, donc même température et
80 % d'humidité, là je peux vous dire
que ça se passe plutôt mal et que vous
allez boire beaucoup plus d'eau de soda
ou euh de boissons alcoolisé, mais je
vous en conseille pas d'abuser sur ces
boissons là. Et bien à même température,
en fait, notre corps, il va pas
ressentir un mal-être de la même façon.
Les plantes pareil,
c'est les plantes, c'est différent parce
que les plantes ne sont pas
thermorégulées contrairement à nous. On
essaie de réguler notre température. Par
contre, les animaux, c'est pareil. Les
vaches, c'est pareil. Une vache qui est
en stress thermique, on appelle ça
l'indice th pour la la vache,
température humidité index, c'est
l'umidex pour l'homme. Et bien le
l'indice thi, donc plus il fait chaud,
plus il fait humide, plus la vache va
avoir un mal-être. Donc déjà premier
point, dans une société, on voulait que
les animaux soient bien pendant leur
vie, bah c'est un mauvais point. 2e
point, elle va produire moins de lait
puisque son énergie corporelle va être
plutôt redirigée vers la
thermorégulation.
Elle va produire moins de lait, elle va
moins manger. Donc si elle mange moins,
elle a moins d'énergie pour faire du
lait. Donc c'est des pertes économiques
aussi. Donc c'est de la de la perte
économique et de la perte de bien-être
animal. Donc il faut travailler dessus.
Euh
tu es en train de me dire que plus
l'animal l'animal est en bonne
condition,
moins il y a de perte, donc moins il y a
d'inflation. C'est ça les et l'une des
principales
[Musique]
impact du changement climatique sur le
prix du lait par exemple en été, ça sera
les canicules. S'il y a une canicule
majeure sur l'ensemble de l'Union
européenne et que les vaches produisent
moins, on a moins de production, le prix
du lait augmente forcément et donc le
prix du beurre augmente, le prix du
yaourt augmente. On a eu des
augmentations de prix, on a eu des
diminutions de production en 2022, mais
c'était couplé aussi avec la guerre en
Ukraine. Donc c'était un peu difficile
de discerner qui faisait quoi. Donc pour
faire face à ces év à ces événements là,
soit il y a plusieurs façons. Soit on
remonte la production laitière vers le
nord, soit on la remonte en altitude.
Mais en tout cas dans le sud de
l'Europe, ce sera plus facile de
produire du lait. il faudra passer
plutôt sur l'ovin, le caprin. Donc ça
veut dire que les pays du sud de
l'Europe vont être dépendants du lait
euh du nord de l'Europe.
Euh euh ou ou soit on peut aussi lutter
en ayant des races plus résistantes,
parfois moins productives ou sur les
bâtiments d'élevage en isolant mieux les
bâtiments d'élevage notamment en
Bretagne où il a fait 40°gr plusieurs
fois depuis 3 ans, ce qui était jamais
arrivé auparavant. Donc les bâtiments
d'élevage qui étaient présents n'étaient
pas du tout adaptés à à ce changement
climatique. Donc voilà. Euh il y a aussi
il y a pas que l'humain qui subit euh
ses fortes chaleurs et cette humidité,
il y a également euh les animaux
d'élevage. Alors il y a pas que euh des
chaleurs humides qui vont être présentes
dans le monde. Il y aura aussi des
chaleurs sèches. Et c'est là où ça
impacte les plantes. Ça impacte plus les
plantes sur ces chaleurs sèches parce
que quand il fait sec, on a plus d'évapu
transpiration, la plante a chaud donc
elle va agrandir moins vite, on aura
moins de rendement pour faire pour faire
très simple. Et ça c'est le cas de
l'Espagne par exemple. L'Espagne est un
pays en fait c'est notre verger de
l'Europe.
C'est notre
verger qui est un peu en hydroponique
quand même.
Oui, c'est un verger bon très très
perfusé. Moi, j'appelle ça perfusé à
l'eau. C'est ceci dit la principale le
principal producteur de fruits et
légumes en Europe, c'est l'Espagne. Donc
nos marchés dépendent de l'Espagne.
L'Espagne en fait a une structure de
l'eau au niveau du pays qui était très
intéressante, qui a été faite sous
franco, il me semble. Bon, il a fait
plein de choses qui étaient pas
forcément bonnes, mais en tout cas au
niveau de l'eau, il a essayé de gérer au
niveau du territoire pour le pour
l'agriculture. Donc l'Espagne a eu un
accès à l'eau important et a fait
beaucoup de monocultur et donc ils se
sont pas forcément attardés sur
l'agriculture de conservation des sols,
le le de de travailler sur les espèces,
de travailler sur la qualité aussi comme
on fait beaucoup plus notamment en
France parce que chez nous en France, on
n pas forcément l'accès à l'eau qui
vient de partout. On essaie de
travailler sur d'autres options pour
faire face aux sécheresses. L'Espagne,
c'est pas forcément le cas. Et bien
cette Espagne-là, maintenant qu'on a une
sécheresse hiver, une sécheresse
estivale qui se sent enchaîné et ben le
sol s'est asséché. Le sol s'est asséché,
les productions se sont effondrées et
donc on est sur une problématique qui
est beaucoup plus importante que la
France. Eux, c'est une problématique de
désertification, c'est de dégricole.
Donc si on y réfléchit bien parce que
apparemment tu aimes bien parler des
marchés et également des prix. Si on y
réfléchit bien, l'Espagne va perdre son
monopole, on va dire des fruits et
légumes du fait du climat qui s'assèche.
Qui est-ce qui doit reprendre ce
monopole ? Ce sont les pays dans la
partie centrale de l'Europe, le climat
remontant, la tomate, la courgette, le
melon, l'olive, l'olive dans le
sud-ouest de la France, dans le sud-est
de la France, tous ces pays-là en fait,
on a des opportunités économiques
importantes en France, dans les Vallées
suisses, dans le nord de l'Italie, ça
dépendra de l'eau. Dans le sud même de
l'Allemagne, on pourra produire ces
futurs fruits et légumes. Et pour
l'instant, ce qu'on fait, c'est qu'on
attend que l'Espagne s'effondre sans
rien faire.
Et quand si on attend encore que
l'Espagne s'effondre et qu'on a plus ses
fruits et légumes, forcément les prix
vont augmenter. L'agroclimatologie c'est
anticiper en fait cette évolution de la
biogéographie, l'aire de répartition des
espèces de ces cultures
pour éviter l'augmentation des prix dans
l'avenir, de se prendre le mur et de se
dire "Bon bah maintenant, on va
commencer à travailler sur de la
création de filière alors qu'il faut 15
à 30 ans pour les faire."
La l'agroclimatologie, ça nous permet
d'éviter ces hausses de de prix de
denrée alimentaire qui seront
inévitables dans l'avenir si on ne
travaille pas sur l'agroclimatologie.
Donc l'agrocim
l'agroclimatologie c'est anticiper.
C'est de l'anticipation. Voilà.
D'accord. Et la politique c'est quoi ?
de la gestion symptomatique.
Ah bah là, moi pour l'instant ce que je
vois, alors je vais peut-être être un
petit peu critique avec les politiques.
Ce que je vois pour l'instant c'est une
politique du pensement, c'est-à-dire
sur une jambe de bois.
Sur une jambe de bois.
Ouais.
Comment ça ? C'est une expression
française ? Non, je ne connais pas.
Pensement sur une jambe de bois.
C'està-dire qu'en gros euh
tu sens plus ta jambe mais c'est pas
grave, on t'a mis un petit pansement.
arrête de pleurer.
Bah moi, je parle plutôt des vases qu'on
a plutôt du côté du Liban et qu'on met
des petits pansements pour pas qu'il se
casse. Donc donc en fait la politique
que je vois actuellement sur le
changement climatique et même ce que je
j'ai vu même depuis très longtemps,
c'est une politique du pensement. Quand
il y a un événement climatique, on a des
plus des enveloppes de plusieurs
millions, on met le pansement et on
attend l'année suivante en se disant
j'espère qu'il n'y aura pas dejà de
l'année suivante. Inchallah. Ouais,
c'est un peu ça. En réalité, faire face
au changement climatique, c'est pas
mettre des petits pansements, des
petites enveloppes, c'est aller à la
source du problème et essayer de le
résoudre. Parce que additionner tous ces
pansements dû au climat, si on les
additionne, on aurait pu dès l'origine
il y a 30 ans euh travailler sur les
futures filières, les futures
résistances agricoles par rapport au
climat. Euh voilà, pour l'instant ce que
je vois, c'est la politique du
pensement. J'ai un espoir quand même
avec les dernières discussions que j'ai
eu avec le ministère qu'on avance enfin
sur une politique de retour à la source
des problèmes et de résoudre les
problèmes à la source, c'est-à-dire euh
la gestion de l'eau, la vie du sol, euh
la gestion des paysages et également euh
la répartition des zones de production
dans l'avenir. Et je tiens à préciser
quand même que c'est pas uniquement le
rôle des agriculteurs de se soucier de
tous ces problèmes puisque ce qu'on voit
pour l'instant c'est des agriculteurs
qui travaille sur la pistache de France
notamment du côté de Cavaillon. On a la
pistache de France. Ce sont des
agriculteurs qui ont eu cette idée qui
se regroupent pour faire de la pistache.
Très intéressant. La pistache fraîche
d'ailleurs qu'on mange au Moyen-Orient
est vachement plus bonne que la pistache
sèche salée qu'on mange ici en Europe,
je tiens à le préciser. Donc il
travaille sur cette pistache
et
ça ça ça vient d'eux en fait ça vient
des agriculteurs cette idée de
travailler sur les pistaches. En
réalité, je verrai plutôt l'inverse, je
verrai plutôt l'État qui travaille en se
disant voilà on a une zone climatique
qui va être intéressante pour faire un
AOP, un ISGP pistage de France. un
peut-être un futur AOC, un futur IGP euh
euh abricu sec d'Agentin à la place des
des prunau d'Agentin. Peut-être que dans
l'avenir on aura les bières au sorgot de
Toulouse, qu'on aura les pâtes au sorgot
de Toulouse, les biscuits au sorgot de
de Provence. Dans l'avenir, on aura
peut-être le hou représentatif de Lyon
euh parce qu'on aura le poids chiche qui
pourra être plus résistant que le poids
protéagineux qu'on a actuellement en
France.
En fait, on on doit recréer
l'agriculture de demain. On doit pas
juste mettre des petits pansements. On
doit repartir de zéro et se donner
l'ambition de recréer nos plats
nationaux, de recréer notre agriculture
de demain avec l'agriculture qu'on aura
d'ici là en 2050 voire même en 2100.
C'est pas juste se dire on aura toujours
les mêmes cultures au même endroit et je
donne des enveloppes de plusieurs
millions, de plusieurs milliards quand
il y a des problèmes. Non. Et puis ça
peut être un jeu également. Ça peut être
un jeu de recréer ses futures recettes.
Pourquoi pas quelqu'un qui se lance dans
dans une bière au sorgot ? quelqu'un qui
se lance sur un futur cassoulé, je sais
pas, avec une variante, avec des des
aspects, il y a il y a il y a une
entreprise française très connue pour
ses fruits et ses jus de fruits et ses
compotes qui s'est lancé dans le beurre
de cacahuète français parce qu'on
cultive de plus en plus de cacahuètes en
France puisque ça peut faire face au
changement climatique et et pourquoi pas
avoir un IGP, un AOP dans l'avenir
cacahuète du périgor à la place de la
noix du périgor. Pourquoi pas avoir le
noix de cajou du périgor ? En fait, on a
on a un boulevard devant nous.
L'agroclimatologie, c'est un boulevard.
Sauf que derrière nous, on se traîne des
boulets. Des boulets qui sont, désolé
les politiques, qui sont toujours sur
leurs historiques et leurs habitudes. Et
on a derrière nous le boulette de la
tradition.
Libanis qui parle.
Comment
c'est le Libanais qui parle ?
Ah, désolé. Oui, je je je je critique un
petit peu la la politique française.
Mais
tu peux tu peux parce que quand quand
les Français vont connaître la même
chose qu'au Liban, ça va leur
ça va leur faire du bien.
Il faut Non, ça ça va pas leur faire du
bien, mais ils vont ils vont comprendre
le flegme et le calme libanais.
Et et et en fait, on se traîne aussi un
boulet qui est le poids de la tradition.
Alors, le poids de la tradition, je
tiens à le préciser, en France, c'est
l'excellence de l'agriculture française.
C'était quelque chose qui nous a bâti la
tradition, les vins, le fromage. Ça
c'est l'excellence française. On est
l'une des agricultures les plus
excellentes du monde en terme de
production alimentaire. Mais mais il
faut pas que ça devienne un boulet.
Et tu sais pourquoi on fait du fromage
en France ? Tu sais pourquoi on mange
des grenouilles, ? Tu sais pourquoi on
mange de des des huîres ? Tu sais
pourquoi on fait du saucisson ?
Je me suis jamais posé ces questions là.
Le saucisson, le fromage. Tu sais
pourquoi on fait du saucisson du fromage
?
Non. Tu vas me dire
bah parce que c'est pour conserver les
aliments.
Bah voilà, je quelque chose.
Les les salaisons. Les salaisons euh
c'est quand l'hiver arrive, tu manges du
saucisson.
Oui.
Et le fromage, pourquoi on garde des
fromages qui durent très longtemps ? Bah
c'est pour en fait lisser l'apport
calorifique
sur l'année. Oui,
sur l'année.
OK. Ben, j'apprends quelque chose.
Merci. Merci de de m'avoir appris ça.
Mais
mais c'est pas que ça mais ça fait en
partie que en partie ça.
Oui.
les le cette tradition française qui qui
n'est pas à remettre en cause parce
qu'on on est quand même très bon dans
les produits que nous faisons sur nos
terroirs,
il faut pas que ça devienne un boulet
parce que si on veut toujours faire
les pruneaux d'Agin au même endroit, si
on veut toujours faire les il faut
changer de tradition,
il faut savoir intelligemment, c'est pas
bêtement sans réfléchir, remettre en
cause cette tradition et en fait c'est
pas juste la remettre en cause, c'est
juste la déplacer. La déplacer et en
recréer une autre. Et tu dis quoi aux
gens qui font ça qui ont par exemple 150
ans d'ancienneté à faire du pinard à
Bordeaux ?
Bah
tu leur dis écoute moi, tu es tu es
grand, tu es sympa, tu as tu as plein de
pognons en ce moment parce que les
Chinois ils t'ont racheté, bah tu vas
acheter euh des futurs terrains en
Bretagne.
Ils le font déjà.
Ah bah ils le font déjà. La bigographie
de la ville, c'est la plus célèbre de
France. Euh du côté de Cognac, on achète
déjà des terres un peu plus au nord. Du
côté de Bordeaux, on achète déjà des
terres en Normandie. Il y a déjà des
investisseurs qui investissent pour
faire de la vine dans le nord de la
France. La première cuvée du déo de
France, c'était cette année. C'est
Terrenovo, terrooveo, je désolé si je me
trompe, a fait la première cuvée de vin
cette année en France. Je suis allé en
Bretagne, il commençait déjà à faire de
la vigne
et en Angleterre, il y aura des vignes.
En Belgique, il y aura des vignes et et
anticiper parce que la vigne quand on la
plante maintenant, il y a 30 ans de
production. Donc ils vont nous dire
"C'est qui ce mec qui débarque avec sa
vigne là dans le nord ?" Bah ouais, mais
le mec qui vient de débarquer avec sa
ville dans 20 ans, c'est le roi du
pétrole, c'est le roi du vent plutôt
puisqu'il aura en fait un climat qui lui
sera favorable. Et alors j'ai pas besoin
d'aller leur dire aux viticulteurs, ils
font déjà l'effort par contre c'est un
petit peu plus compliqué déjà l'efforts
parce queils sent
ils ont les moyens
ils ont les moyens mais ils sentent
aussi que ça sent le roussi en terme
il voit les les vendes se décaler
les vendes se décalent les les perires
de rendement sont plus importantes bon
la grê c'est autre chose mais il y a
également le gel on a également le
milieu cette année qui a provoqué
beaucoup de dégâts. Euh ils voient les
choses en fait ils ont pas attendu qu'un
agroclimatologue vienne et leur dise ce
qu'il se passe. Ils l'observent déjà les
les agriculteurs. Ils ont déjà commencé
depuis 30 ans à réfléchir à ça. Il faut
juste vraiment un leader charismatique
au niveau politique pour emmener, je dis
pas que les leaders sont pas
charismatiques, même si j'essaie de le
sous-entendre, qui pour emmener cette
agriculture, ces idées qu'on a sur le
terrain pour en faire quelque chose
vraiment de l'agriculture du futur.
Est-ce que tu crois dans un ami
imaginaire ?
Est-ce que tu crois en quelque chose ?
Tu tu es tu es religieux, pas religieux
? Gros Père Noël,
c'est une grande question déjà avec mes
enfants en ce moment. Non, je ne crois
pas au Père Noël et je suis pas
forcément religieux. Vous les
problématiques que ça cause dans mon
pays d'origine, la religion. Donc je me
dédouine de tout ce qui est religion.
Moi, tout ce que je crois c'est la
science. C'est vraiment les choses qui
me guident. C'est les résultats
scientifiques. C'est ce qui me fait
avancer. C'est ce qui fait virer. C'est
ce qui me passionne en réalité.
Et j'ai pas forcément d'autres
croyances. Je me base sur les données
scientifiques. J'ai pas d'idéologie
particulière comme Saint Thomas.
Je connais pas Saint-Thomas.
Je connais peut-être Saint Charbel au
Liban mais alors Saint-Thomas je ne
connais pas. C'est une boutade. Tu ne
crois que ce que tu vois. Revenons au JC
rapport du Jek et et j'ai une question à
te poser. Tu traînes beaucoup sur les
réseaux sociaux. Tu essayes de faire de
la pédagogie sur les réseaux sociaux.
Tu dois te faire insulter à longueur de
journée par certaines personnes
peut-être très énervé.
Qu'est-ce que Comment tu perçois la
défiance envers la science ? Comment tu
perçois la défiance ? Maintenant, je
crois qu'il y a un français sur deux qui
devient défiant avec la science. Je me
dem je demande à faire à me faire fat
checker
le fameux climatoscepticisme
nouveau terme générique pour mettre les
défiants.
H
et quelle politique il faut adopter pour
être bienveillant, être pédagogue ?
Comment on fait pour essayer d'enseigner
sans radicaliser encore plus les gens ?
Parce que nous notre perception c'est
plus tu auras tendance à leur mettre des
grandes claques dans la tête, à les
insulter d'imbile toute la journée,
à ne pas garder son calme face à des
gens qui sont en demande d'information,
en demande de pédagogie pour la majeure
partie,
plus tu leur mets des claques, moins ça
fonctionne. Donc toi, quelle position tu
adoptes quand il y a tu as des
climatosceptiques ou des
climatodéfiants, appelle ça comme tu
veux, des gens qui qui pour eux leur
échauffement climatique
dû à l'activité humaine n'existe pas
quand ils te sorte que l'optimum
médiéval de telle année, il faisait
encore plus froid, il faisait encore
plus chaud, que avant le Groenland
s'était ouvert
et que les Vikings, ils étaient très
contents en maillot de bain là-bas.
C'est une boutade mais
Oui, c'est une boutade d'ailleurs très
mal placée. Quelle position tu adoptes
pour être le plus pédagogique possible ?
C'est du genre à mettre des grandes
claques, tu enlèves ton chapeau sur le
fouet.
J'enlève jamais mon chapeau.
C'est pas vrai. Tu as enlevé ton chapeau
avant le direct. Ça faut pas faut pas le
dire ça. C'est il faut garder le mur.
Mais tu es quand même sacré beau gosse
sans chapeau. D'ailleurs, tu tu veux pas
enlever ton chapeau de camargué ? Je
l'enlèverai peut-être à la fin de
l'émission si vous êtes sages,
mais on n'est jamais sage donc tu peux
garder ton chapeau.
Alors le climatoscepticisme
effectivement quand on est présent sur
Twitter on y fait face. On y fait face
forcément. Moi pour vous donner un
chiffre, ça peut paraître étonnant mais
je reçois une centaine d'insultes par
jour pendant quel type ?
Alors ça a évolué à l'époque il y a 2
ans euh quand j'étais un petit peu moins
connu et quand le climatoscepti n'était
pas forcément très présent sur Twitter,
présent mais pas trop. Et bien on avait
quand même des arguments, on avait des
gens qui essayaient de comprendre, qui
essayent d'argumenter. Puis on est
rapidement passé en été à il y avait
plus d'arguments, on est passé à
l'attaque physique, les insultes. J'ai
même reçu des insultes racistes.
Retourne dans ton pays, t'occuper de
l'agriculture, ton pays, les gens
crèvent de faim. Euh des Alors, mes
collègues ont des insultes,
on dit fémin misogyne, féministe, je je
je connais pas très bien toutes les
définitions. Matchiste, voilà. Euh et
bien euh et bien euh on a une évolution,
maintenant on est vraiment passé sur la
l'attaque à la personne pour essayer de
faire terire la personne parce qu'en
général ils ont plus d'arguments euh vu
les arguments sur le changement
climatique qui s'accumule. l'épreuve, il
y a un moment on attaque la personne.
Alors moi, j'ai une vision un petit peu
particulière de ce climatoscepticisme et
ce qui m'est personnel euh puisque j'ai
toujours été un peu différent à l'école,
j'étais à Versailles déjà, je suis pas
du tout prototype Versaillé par
excellence.
Vers en banieu de Beout,
non, Versailles en banlieu de de Paris.
Euh donc, j'étais très différent dans ma
façon de m'habiller. Je chassais leur
âge. Moi, c'était pas du tout faire ce
que les Versaillés faisaient. Moi je je
je allais pas à la messe ?
Je suis allée à la messe oui pendant une
certaine partie de ma vie et quand j'ai
eu le choix, j'y allais plus.
C'est une traduction,
j'allais chasser l'orage. Pour moi,
c'est un petit peu regarder le ciel,
c'est un petit peu pour moi euh un petit
peu ma spiritualité mais sans sans Dieu.
Euh et bien euh je me rappelle plus où
où j'étais là. Tu tu m'as perdu.
Non, je t'ai pas perdu.
C'est toi qui t'es perdu et je fais
exprès de te perdre avec la foudre
divine bientôt qu'on va aborder.
Donc tu étais à Versailles, donc tu
avais déjà une activité qui
Voilà, ça me revient. Donc j'avais
l'habitude d'avoir des critiques.
J'avais un chapeau, j'avais l'habitude
d'avoir des critiques. Donc arrivé sur
Twitter, j'ai l'impression de retourner
au lycée
et d'avoir des attaques de type lycéen
extrêmement bête. Euh donc moi je je
prends la position un petit peu de
l'humour mais sans l'humour. Pourquoi tu
qualifies ça d'extrêmement bête ?
Pourquoi ?
Parce que à l'époque des lycéens, il y
avait on se faisait attaquer de façon,
on va dire mais
si tu as cette perception,
c'est que toi aussi tu manques de
maturité.
C'est-à-dire que si pour toi c'est des
attaques de lycéen,
c'est que tu n'as pas pris suffisamment
de hauteur d'adulte pour rassurer la
personne en priorité qui est en face de
toi
et d'avoir quelque chose qui peut
glisser sur toi parce que tu vois une
catégorie de personnes en face de toi en
détresse ou en demande et verbaliser sa
demande d'une façon agressive.
Désolé si je te contredis mais je me
permets. Je pense qu'on est quand même
dans je veux pas acquieresser tout ce
que tu dis. Je ne peux pas qualifier par
exemple l'association des
climatoréalistes comme des personnes en
détresse.
Non mais non si c'est une association
c'est qui on connait pas cation. Ce sont
des personnes qui racontent n'importe
quoi sur les réseaux sociaux, qui
manipulent les chiffres et qui vont te
dire qu'il n'y a pas de changement
climatique ou qu'il y a une
stabilisation du climat entre 2015 et
2022 sans regarder ce qui se passe
depuis 1880. Quoi ? Ce sont pas des
personnes en détresse. Il y a des
personnes qui font exprès de balancer de
fausses informations qui ont des
intérêts peut-être derrière. Alors, il y
a peut-être des personnes en détresse
qui croient croivent croi à à ces je
désolé mais à ces personnes-là euh et et
qui qui sont peut-être qui n'ont pas
forcément la formation scientifique pour
démêler le vrai du faux. Effectivement,
peut-être que ce sont des personnes en
détresse qui se font emporter dans un
discours qui n'est pas forcément
rationnel et scientifique, mais je ne
peux pas dire que les climatodénialiste
présents sur Twitter qui balancent des
fake news tous les 4 matins avec des
faux articles et qui manipulent les
données et qui prennent une petite
partie du chéri qui prennent juste une
petite partie, je ne peux pas dire
qu'ils sont qu' sont quel est le terme
que tu as employaé déjà ? Qu' sont naïfs
ou qui qui comprennent pas. Alors, il y
a deux catégories climatosceptiques.
Ceux qui sont embarqués par ces espèces
de gourous du faux scientifique qui
savent ce qu'il font.
Pour toi, pour toi, c'est une grande
petite partie, moyenne partie.
Alors, il y a une très petite partie de
personnes qui manipulent l'information
et après il y a une grande partie qui
les suivent euh sans comprendre vraiment
ce qui se passe qu's ont pas les bases
de démêlé forcément.
Et tu as déjà débattu avec eux ? Oui, je
débat avec eux sur euh mes followers sur
Twitter, par exemple, ils peuvent le
dire, hein. Euh et pour revenir
d'ailleurs à ta question d'origine, moi
je j'emploie un minimum de d'humour pour
euh pour répondre au climatoceptique.
C'estàd que quand ils vont nous mettre
un événement, oui, il n'y a pas de
changement climatique depuis 2015 avec
une droite en 2015 voire même qui
diminue. Je leur dire "Bon bah merci
pour vos informations. Je viens d'aller
sur votre source et je viens de prendre
les mêmes données depuis 1880 et là on
voit bien la hausse de la température.
On ne prend pas les 7 dernières années
pour parler du changement climatique.
Merci, bisous, au revoir. En gros, un
peu d'humour, ça marche hyper bien parce
que j'apporte des faits, des faits
scientifiques. Je les contredis sans les
insulter parce que voilà et et mon
objectif c'est pas de de de
on va dire de convaincre les
climatosceptiques qui sont à l'origine
de ces de ces postes. Mon origine mon
objectif pardon, je fatigue. mon
objectif
est de de
convaincre en fait les personnes qui
vont lire ce commentaire et qui dans qui
pourraient y y croire et et et qui
pourrai donc voilà et qui ont une
information complémentaire d'un
scientifique qui leur permet un petit
peu de nuancer cette information. En
général, c'est moi qui essaie de
nuancer. Et donc tu tu débats tu cites
l'exemple sur ce que tu dis du chériing,
c'est-à-dire de prendre de
l'information,
de picotage, ça s'appelle en français.
Cotal,
c'est moi qui t'apprend des mots
maintenant.
Non, ça ça m'étonnerait.
Donc le nihilisme climatique
euh quand tu débats avec des gens qui
euh
sont dans le déni
ou que tu juges instrumentalisé, est-ce
que tu fais leur leur pédigré ? C'estàd
que nous,
on a on a comme comme principe de
toujours essayer d'avoir le maximum
d'information sur les gens. Hm hm.
D'où est-ce qu'ils viennent, d'où est-ce
qu'il parlent, comment ils parlent,
pourquoi ils parlent, comment ils sont
payés, pourquoi il il va les payer,
ainsi de suite.
Est-ce que tu as fait tu as fait le le
le le CV, le curriculum VT de de de ces
personnes ?
Est-ce que tu as proposé d'échanger en
physique sur une longue période,
minimum 2 heures sur des sujets
complexes, c'est c'est un minimum.
Comment ça se passe ? Ils disent oui,
ils disent non. Ils disent que tu es un
cinglet avec un chapeau, que tu dis
souvent un gourou avec un chapeau.
Alors je pour être franc, on peut pas
dire que je débat avec les climats sous
sceptiques parce qu'en général il y a
une information, je l'ai contredit et ça
s'arrête là parce que c'est assez fort,
on va dire, comme élément scientifique
pour ne pas aller plus loin dans le
débat. Je n'ai jamais vraiment engagé
une conversation en physique puisque ce
sont des comptes anonymes généralement
qui m'attaquent et qui ne veulent pas
sortir de l'anonymat. Par contre, quand
je suis en conférence et que j'ai
quelques agriculteurs climatceptiques,
ça m'est arrivé je peux engager une
conversation avec eux, essayer de les
comprendre, essayer de les aider aussi à
mieux comprendre l'aspect scientifique
de l'histoire. Donc ça m'intéresse pas
forcément par contre d'interagir avec
des climatosceptiques beaucoup plus
longtemps parce que j'ai plus
l'impression en fait avec l'expérience
de perdre mon temps. Je je perds mon
temps et je pense que le temps d'un
agroclimatologue surtout quand il y en a
pas beaucoup en France, il est précieux
pour faire avancer l'agriculture et
faire avancer la politique sur
l'agriculture. Perdre son temps avec les
climatosceptiques à essayer deinteragir
avec eux physiquement, leur donner
rendez-vous. Je peux pas encore le caser
dans mon emploi du temps. Ça peut être
envisageable mais c'est pas forcément ce
qui est prioritaire chez moi.
De socioperception parce que il y a de
plus en plus de climat sceptique où il y
en a de plus en plus. Est-ce que est-ce
que c'est pas contre-productif d'avoir
ton attitude de pas vouloir prendre le
temps
en envisageant le futur plus calme ?
C'estàd que nous nous ce qu'on voit d'un
point de vue extérieur c'est
ça se tartine à longueur de journée
entre les pro, les comptes, les pour,
les pas pour, les climat machin, les
climat bidul
startine. Le résultat est le suivant. Il
y a de plus en plus de gens qui qui
contestent la science. Hm
hm.
Il y a de plus en plus de
climatosceptiques. Hm
hm.
Donc est-ce que dans la démarche tu as
peut-être loupé quelque chose en terme
de pédagogie pour anticiper le long
terme ? Parce que le, imagine-toi h
le politique court termiste
symptomatique
qui va se présenter peut-être dans 10
ans aux élections
et qui aura pas, on va dire, une base de
intellectuelle dans la population pour
dire ce que tu me racontes là politique
populiste,
c'est pas un petit peu de
l'agropoliticoclimatologie
à long terme de mettre sa population en
accord avec sa science supportant sa
science. Non
mais je je sais pas, je te trouve un peu
naïf quand même sur cette question là.
Des naïfs mon pote. Alors
moi je je suis plus que l'agriculteur
qui plante son arbre. Je fais des plans
à 15 ans minimum.
OK si tu le dis.
Tous les gens qui me connaissent savent
que je réfléchis à moyen et très long
terme. Hm
hm. Hm hm. Alors, faut faire attention
quand tu dis que les climatosceptiques
sont de plus en plus nombreux. En
réalité, il y a la majorité silencieuse
qui joue là et la minorité silencieuse,
c'est un cas parfait pour parler de ça.
Les climats oceétiques sont très
bruyants, mais ils ne sont pas non plus
présents dans la société, on va dire en
dehors de Twitter. Ils sont pas partout
dans la rue comme on peut le voir aussi
bruyamment sur Twitter. En réalité, la
majorité de la population et surtout la
population avec laquelle je travaille,
les agriculteurs. 80
sources de de ça.
Quelles sont mes sources de ça ? C'est
ma vraie vie en fait.
D'accord.
C'est c'est les conférences que je fais
tous les jours. J'en fais énormément en
fait.
Combien de personnes ça représente à la
fin de l'année ?
Alors, je fais une centaine de
conférences par an. En moyenne, il doit
y avoir là, il y avait 200 personnes ce
matin, par exemple.
Ça fait ça fait beaucoup de monde quand
même.
Ça fait combien ?
100 x 200 Ça fait combien ? 20000 ?
Ouais, 20000. Ouais. Intrige 20000
agriculteurs, c'est quand même pas mal
qui après peuvent transférer
l'information à d'autres agriculteurs.
Et s
et l'information si tu dis. Il y a pas
que les conférences qui sont
importantes, il y a également mon rôle
de en tant que scientifique, je
travaille également avec des entreprises
agroalimentaires. Je travaille également
maintenant du coup sur
elle te rémunère ?
Bah oui, elle me rémunère. Je travaille
sur de la data, je travaille sur de la
modélisation. C'est un travail en fait.
Combien tu gagnes ? Ça dépendait moi et
là c'est tellement compliqué avec la
création d'entreprise entre le passage
de la de l'autre entreprise la création
d'entreprise que je ne sais même pas
j'ai pas de fiche de paye encore.
Tu passes un plafond de 76000 € à un
euh Non non, je ne passe pas de plafond
de 76000 €. J'ai dépassé un plafond de
39000 € là euh dans l'out entreprise qui
correspond à un plafond de taxe euh en
en 7 mois. Prat temporis, méfie-toi.
Pratemporis au
T'inquiète aux impôts, ils vont
t'expliquer. Et
alors, j'ai pas encore de fiche de paye
fixe. Ce sera à partir de janvier chez
Agroclimat 2050 la structure que j'ai
créé, donc je peux pas dire combien je
gagne. Euh euh ça dépend des mois. Il y
a en par exemple en août et juillet,
j'ai pas fait de conférence puisque
c'est pas le moment où fait des
conférences. J'ai plus fait du du
consulting où j'ai gagné 0 € parce que
c'est des modèles que je préparais pour
l'automne. Il y a des mois où je peux
gagner 5000 € mais qui compensent
brut ou net.
Euh alors sur la micro-entreprise
c'était en net. En net.
Donc c'est bien.
C'est bien mais il y a des mois où je
gagne pas forcément autant. Donc en
moyenne je je m'y retrouve sur l'année.
Après, je suis pas quelqu'un de très
dépensier en réalité. Euh et bien euh
on parlait de quoi avant de parler de de
ces sujets sur le climatcepicisme ? Je
sais pas si tu veux qu'on revienne
dessus. intérêt. Vas-y, fais-toi
plaisir.
Je je je suis quand même pas forcément
d'accord sur cette idée de forcément
discuter avec eux parce que j'ai essayé
en il y a 2 ans 3 ans à l'époque où je
me faisais insulter
et j'avais l'impression d'avoir des
chiens enragés en face de moi. Et vous
savez quand vous avez une famille que
qu'on a du boulot, qu'on a plein de
choses, il y a un moment on se dit "Bon,
je je vais plus perdre mon temps. Pour
moi, j'ai j'ai perdu mon temps. Ce que
je vais faire, c'est que ils ont un
poste climatoceptique. Je vais le
reprendre. Je vais analyser les données
moi-même et je vais rediffuser une des
données qui sont plus scientifiques,
peut-être plus longues sur le temps et
qui contredisent en fait ces
climatosceptique.
Mon objectif pour moi n'est plus de
convaincre les climatosceptiques. Je
pense que ça prend trop de temps et mon
temps est quand même précieux pour
d'autres choses. Et et par contre, ne
pas faire tâche d'huile et rapporter
plus de monde, c'est là où je travaille.
C'est-à-dire en ayant un complément
d'information dans les commentaires en
bas.
Tu me disais que tu as discuté avec
quelques agriculteurs qui étaient
climatosceptiques.
Est-ce que tu peux me donner de
l'information ? Qu'est-ce que tu en as
perçu ? Comment tu les as sondé ?
Qu'est-ce que tu as identifié ? Comment
tu as quel langage tu as utilisé ?
Comment tu t'es adapté ? Et surtout
qu'est-ce que tu en déduit ?
Alors effectivement, c'est très rare
mais ça m'arrive en conférence des des
personnes qui viennent me voir plutôt
climatceptiques avec des commentaires
"Mais ce sont des cycles, mais c'est le
soleil qui se rapproche de la Terre,
mais enfin des trucs euh parfois tu te
demandes d'où ça sort." Euh et là ce qui
est intéressant c'est qu'en
agroclimatologie on n'a pas que le
thermomètre.
C'est la Terre qui se rapproche du
soleil. Non, il a dit ça comme ça. C'est
ça.
Oui, mais en fait le soleil grossi donc
il va nous enir au bout d'un moment.
Mais c'est dans plusieurs années. Dans
de plusieurs années, dans plusieurs
milliards et des milliards d'années, je
sais pas combien c'est l'astronomie.
quand le soleil se transforma en géant
rouge.
Ouais, c'est c'est ça peut-être. Et euh
et en fait euh alors en conférence quand
on en physique, je suis extrêmement
pédagogue. C'est-à-dire que je vais leur
dire, il n'y a pas que le thermomètre
monsieur qui permet de de mesurer
l'augmentation de la température. Il y a
également les dates de vendange. Les
dates de vendange à Bone par exemple, on
a des séries, je me rappelle plus des
noms des scientifiques qui ont travaillé
dessus, mais il y a un papier et c'est
dans le rapport du GC. Depuis 1371, on a
les dates de vendange avec une avancée
des dates de vendange reliée à la
température de 15 jours. Maintenant, on
a des dates de vendange qui apparaissent
fin août. Ça, c'est mon thermomètre.
C'est le thermomètre d'un
agroclimatologue. Tu parles en vendange
tardive ou en vendange normale ? Non,
toute chose égale par ailleurs. Toute
chose égale par ailleurs. C'est page
égal par ailleurs.
On a également les dates de floraison
des cerisiers du Japon qui été mesuré
par les moines
ou d'autres personnes de à l'époque
depuis 812
des moines forcément
depuis plus d'un millénaire 812. Donc on
a des évolutions du climat naturel. On
voit des périodes où le la de floraison
la date de floraison est reliée aussi à
la température et au froid en hiver.
Et bien, on a des variations avec des
variations plus longues comme ça, donc
des cycles naturels de l'évolution du
climat en et d'un coup avec
l'urbanisation et le changement
climatique parce que c'est des des
cerisiers qui sont à Kyoto que j'ai dans
mon graphique mais c'est la même chose
en dehors des villes. Et bien on a un
décrochage complet en dans les années
1900 et on a des dates de floraison
maintenant à 20 jours d'avance par
rapport à avant. Ça c'est mon
thermomètre. Et quand je leur montre ces
résultats climatoceptiques de
l'agriculture, et bien là, ils sont ils
ont le sourire. Ils sortent, ils se
disent "Il m'a convaincu effectivement
quand on me parle de la vendange, quand
on me parle des dates de floraison, ça
me parle un peu plus." Et voilà, il y a
pas que des éléments aussi climatiques
pour répondre au climatoceptique. Il y a
des éléments agroclimatiques,
les glaciers, les cernes aussi des
arbres. Il y a une science qui étudie
ça. Il y a également la floraison, les
vendances,
chronologie, c'est ça
là. C'est ça. Euh ça c'est des choses
qu'on peut pas trafiquer. Comme on dit
qu'on trafique les thermomètres, ça on
peut pas le trafiquer. Et donc ça permet
d'avoir vraiment euh voilà des preuves,
des arguments pour parler. Donc ça c'est
des arguments que j'apporte souvent
quand des climatosceptiques vont me dire
sur internet, on a trafiqué les
thermomètres ou alors les thermomètres
sont dans des aéroports ou en ville. Moi
je leur apporte les dates de floraison,
les dates de vendange, les trucs
historiques. En fait, il y a un
maronier, on peut se reconnecter avec.
C'est ça.
Ouais, on peut se reconner avec quelque
chose que qui est concret quoi. La date
de floraison, par exemple du maronnier
en face de l'hôtel de ville de Genève
déclarait officiellement l'arrivée du
printemps. On a gagné un mois sur
l'arrivée du printemps. Bon, à l'époque,
c'est parce qu'on changeait de taxe il y
a très longtemps, mais depuis les années
1800, on a gagné un mois d'avancée sur
la date de florison du marinier
japonais. Alors, il y a l'urbanisation,
mais pas que. Il y a également
l'évolution du climat et ça c'est des
choses qui sont indiscutables. On n pas
mis des puces 5G dans un arbre en 1800
pour qu'il fleurisse plus tard. Euh
ça c'est un argument qui t'a été sorti
le coup des plus 5G dans les arbres
euh
ou c'est euh beaucoup on on m'a déjà
parlé par les plus 5G mais les ondes qui
peuvent influencer peut-être aussi les
dates de vendange et tout enfin
souvent quand on n pas d'argumence
souvent on se tourne vers des choses que
je n'arrive pas à comprendre et ça en
fait partie aussi donc des personnes qui
connaissent pas du tout
l'agroclimatologie qui vont te sortir
des choses assez monstrueuses. Est-ce
que dans les groupes de climatologues,
de d'agroclimatologues ou de
scientifiques, vous avez été approché
par des professionnels du dialogue ou
des professionnels de la pédagogie ou
des psychologues, des psychiatres
sans psychiatriser les gens en face ?
Est-ce qu'il y a des gens qui ont essayé
de vous aider
à transmettre
? Pas ma connaissance,
c'est dommage ça.
Pas ma connaissance. Bon, en tant
qu'agroclimatologue, je suis pas dans
des centres de recherche de
climatologue. Je les vois pas tous les
jours, je leur parle sur le téléphone,
Twitter où parfois on se voit. Mais non,
on n pas été abordé par des
professionnels. Enfin, moi en tout cas
professionnel de la résolution des
conflits.
Peut-être dans les centres de recherche
publique, il y a des formations sur
comment communiquer.
Peut-être ça me va pas.
Voilà, je je suis pas au courant. Euh
moi par contre, ça a été l'inverse.
Ce sont des professionnels de la
communication qui sont venus me demander
quelle formation j'ai fait et est-ce que
je pouvais donner des formations ? Ah
non, mais ça ça paraît étonnant mais
c'est que il considère que quand je
réponds aux climatosceptiques sur
Twitter, j'ai une façon de répondre un
peu originale, un petit peu punchy, mais
à la fois en apportant des arguments.
Blague. Non, c'est vrai. Des
professionnels de la communication du
quel type
? Euh alors
des boîtes des des des boîtes de
communication, des boîtes de com ou
alors même des des des pôles de
communication d'entreprises agricoles
qui m'ont demandé de les aider pour
mieux faire face par exemple à à des
problématiques qu'ils ont eu sur le
terrain. Bon en général c'est c ces
réponses là je leur ai dit je peux pas
trop vous aider parce que je sais pas en
fait je saurais pas vous aider. C'est
des choses voilà que que qui sont pas
vraiment de mon ressort. Mais oui ça
paraît étonnant. Euh donc
voilà quand tu me dis
tu es en train de me dire qu'on va faire
du nudge de de communication
pour un sujet qui est central pour nos
sociétés la stabilité de nos sociétés.
C'est-à-dire qu'en gros euh c'est berne
en mode propaganda nudge pour s'adresser
à notre population, c'estàdire faire
passer le message et ainsi de suite.
Alors que il y a des disciplines comme
la psychologie, la psychiatrie, des gens
qui sont spécialisés dans la résolution
du des conflits, que ce soit des
conflits, des petits conflits ou des
conflits de guerre. H
et c'est des gens de la comig de
startiner ça.
Bah je saurais pas dire sur ce que j'ai
pas fait de formation de communication
donc je connais pas trop tout ça mais
moi il se base par exemple sur ma
pédagogie sur les réseaux sociaux et ils
sont assez étonnés du calme que j'ai
parfois à répondre.
Euh pas de l'enseignement officiel, mais
il m'arrive d'intervenir, oui, dans les
classes pour leur parler de comment
contrer les climatosceptiques.
Commenter les climatosceptiques sur les
Désolé, j'ai j'ai le président dansation
climatologie qui m'appelle. Et bien
comment contrer les climat s'appelle ?
Il s'appelle Laurent Garcelon, président
d'un climat. Je je je sais pas.
D'ailleurs, si tu veux dire bonjour à ta
maman.
Bonjour maman. Bonjour toute ma famille.
On passe le bonjour et on embrasse très
fort le Liban.
Bah écoute,
est-ce que tu peux continuer ? Désolé de
t'avoir coupé. Donc la pédagogie, la
communication,
mais c'est c'est qu'en fait, il trouve
que je suis particulièrement calme quand
je me fais insulter. Il m'arrive souvent
de répondre à pédagogie, d'apporter des
arguments malgré qu'on m'insulte et ils
veulent savoir comment je fais. Je sais
pas trop quoi leur répondre parce que je
je sais pas quoi leur répondre. Je je
voilà, j'arrive pas à expliquer mais ils
veulent essayer de comprendre voilà
comment garder son calme sur les réseaux
sociaux, comment toujours garder de la
pédagogie et
voilà, c'est pas une histoire que je
dois leur donner une formation et leur
faire Non, c'est aussi comprendre aussi
les réseaux sociaux parce que les
personnes qui sont présentes dans les
boîtes de communication ou qui sont dans
des pôles communication entreprise,
c'est pas forcément des personnes qui
sont familières avec les réseaux
sociaux. Moi je trouve ça intéressant
qu'il viennent me voir pour pour me
poser des questions. Enfin, je pensais
pas que ça allait détonner mais je te
mens pas en disant ça. Mais c'est c'est
assez rare. C'est peut-être arrivé cinq
fois en 3 ans, mais ça reste
relativement rare par rapport à d'autres
questions que j'ai sur le climat quand
même.
Question internet.
Est-ce que alors je vais synthétiser
Attends attends attends sur les semences
euh paysane. Ça te parle ? Ça te parle
pas ? Bien sûr.
Qu'est-ce que tu penses fait que
certaines semences soient pas autorisées
ou parce qu'elle est pas référencée dans
le bon livre de du livre de machin ?
Pourquoi on fait ça ? Est-ce que avoir
des semences qui sont dites entre
guillemets paysanes ou ancestrales ou ça
peut poser des problèmes à d'autres ou
comment ça se passe ?
Alors ça c'est de la génétique, c'est
pas forcément mon domaine. Donc je sors
de mon domaine, je vais quand même
répondre. Très bien,
je sors de mon domaine et donc n'hésitez
pas à vérifier les informations que je
vais dire. Ouais. Je je alors il me
semble, je dis bien il me semble que
dans la sélection génétique qu'on a eu
actuellement jusqu'à présent, on a
beaucoup sélectionné les gènes de de
beauté des fruits, par exemple, de
résistance à certaines maladies pour
éviter les phytosanitaires,
de production important pour augmenter
la production agricole bien sûr, mais on
a un peu mis de côté tout ce qui est
résistance à la sécheresse, résistance
au canicules parce qu'on avait un climat
stable. Donc on on a vraiment
sélectionné les gènes qui nous
importaient dans un contexte
socio-économique
d'avant. Maintenant, il faut
réintroduire en fait, il faut garder
quand même certaines caractéristiques.
On peut pas tout jeter à la poubelle.
C'est notamment grâce à la génétique
qu'on est sorti des risques de famine en
Europe. On peut pas tout mettre à la
poubelle. Mais ceci dit, il y a
certaines espèces variétés qu'on a
oublié, qu'on a vraiment sélectionné
basé sur quelques quelques uniquement
quelques variétés. Et il faut
réintroduire quand même des gènes de
résistance à la sécheresse au canicou.
Peut-être repenser aux racines aussi
qu'elles aillent plus en profondeur
chercher l'eau. Il n'y a pas que la
beauté du fruit, il n'y a pas que la
production et la résistance aux
maladies. Il y a la résistance aux
sécheresses, aux canicules,
l'utilisation de l'eau aussi pour
produire les denrées alimentaires, euh
les racines, le portrainaire pour aller
chercher de l'eau en profondeur. Il y a
plein de choses à réintroduire sans
jeter ce qui a été déjà fait, mais il
faut penser à reprendre ces semences
parfois paysanes ou des semences
anciennes et faire un mix en fait des
aspects positifs des deux. Euh retourner
par contre uniquement aux semences
paysanes, c'est s'affranchir de
nouvelles résistances aux maladies qu'on
avait avant. Pour moi, il faut faire un
mix pour euh faire face au changement
climatique. Il faut vraiment
réintroduire ces gènes qu'on avait euh
qu'on avait euh oublié. Alors, il faut
faire attention.
C'est pas forcément ma problématique,
c'est pas forcément l'amélioration
génétique parce que c'est quand même un
rôle important la génétique dans
l'agroclimatologie.
Bon, il y a des techniques discutables
sur les OGM, les NTB, c'est en dehors de
l'Europe. Mais euh alors, il faut faire
attention d'avoir cette ce monopole
aussi qu'on a dans certaines entreprises
sur ce monopole génétique qui pour moi
parfois peut me poser problème euh que
certaines il y a que quelques
entreprises mondiales qui permettent de
faire des des de nouvelles variétés,
peut-être un petit peu l'ouvrir pour
avoir une diversité parce que pour moi,
pour faire face au changement
climatique, il faut la diversité
partout, ne pas mettre tous les œufs
dans le même panier. Tu fais pousser des
trucs ?
Euh
alors tu viens en appartement ou en
maison cette année
? Tu viens en maison ?
Oui.
Tu es propriétaire ?
Je suis propriétaire. Euh
quel âge tu as ?
J'ai 34 ans.
Tu as gagné l'auto ?
J'ai pas gagné l'auto et mes parents n'
m'ont donné rien du tout. J'ai construit
ma vie. Oui.
Alors, je ne critique pas mes parents,
mais c'est que quand on est issu de la
guerre du Liban et qu'on arrive sans
rien euh en France et qu'on doit tout
faire de ses mains, ma mère était
infirmière et mon père est mécanicien au
même endroit depuis 30 ans, bah c'est
sûr que j'ai pas un héritage qui me
tombe du ciel et que donc j'ai j'ai
construit moi-même avec mes études et et
mon cerveau, ma maison. Voilà. Enfin, je
l'ai pas construite, je l'ai acheté.
Mais
dans quelle région ?
Au pied du Pic Saint-Loup. à
Montpellier, la plus belle région de
France. Bien sûr, beaucoup plus beau que
le métro parisien, désolé.
Alors, cette année, j'ai planté 17
arbres, 17 arbres fruitiers dans mon
jardin. Euh je je pense que la la
vendeuse d'arbre à côté de la maison là
maintenant, c'est moême ma pote, elle me
voit à chaque fois, elle me dit vous.
C'est quoi comme arbre que tu as planté
? J'ai planté des arbres pour faire des
tests aussi sur ce que je dis pour le
futur.
Des amendiers. Alors, j'avais déjà un
amendier qui malheureusement a beaucoup
souffert de la sécheresse de 2022, a
perdu une partie de ses branches que
j'ai Californie.
California.
En Californie.
Oui, comme en Californie. Euh, je
pensais que c'était une variété
california. Je me suis dit de quoi il
parle. Alors le kaki, la nefle, l'avocat
et l'amande mais et la mangue. Mais ça
c'était vraiment des test vraiment
avec le gel, on risque d'avoir de fortes
pertes. J'ai tous les agrumes, clément,
j'ai quatre oranges qui ont poussé sur
mon orange cette année. Citronnier,
cédra,
non, j'ai pas le cédra euh la figue.
Bon, ça ça va encore en région
méditerranée. J'ai la noix, j'avais déjà
un noyer qui produit pas mal. les
cerises mais des cerises de variété
plutôt d'origine sud Europe que j'essaie
d'adapter à Montpellier. Donc je fais
des tests, c'est pour stocker du
carbone, pour faire de l'ombrage aussi
sur la prairie que j'ai pour pas avoir
le soleil qui c'est pour maîtriser le
microclimat de mon jardin. Bon, ça c'est
une déformation professionnelle mais
ceci dit, j'essaie de faire des tests,
je plante des arbres et je cherche des
pista à chiers en ce moment parce que
j'adore la pistache fraîche. Voilà. Bon,
après, j'ai planté aussi des fleurs mais
ça c'est autre chose. C'est pas pour la
production alimentaire. Donc oui, j'ai
planté 17 arbres dans mon jardin cette
année et je pense que je vais me calmer
parce que sinon ma femme va pas être
trop contente, il y a plus de place.
Tu pourras mettre des balançoires quoi.
J'ai mis des j'ai mis des balançoires
pour les enfants entre l'avocatier et le
nez flier.
Tu parlais des produits phytosanitaires.
Oui.
Euh qu'est-ce que tu penses du fait que
certains déserbants h
soient remis au goût du jour ou
réautorisés pour x années ? Hm
hm. C'est quoi ? C'est une question
économique, c'est-à-dire que on préfère
mettre des déserbants plutôt qu' engager
des gars avec une petite serpette pour
aller faire des kilomètres de voie
ferrée. Euh c'est une question
nécessaire parce que à force de mettre
des déserbants maintenant, on se
retrouve avec des golgottes
de ce qu'ils appellent mauvaises herbes.
Hm hm.
C'est c'est à cause de quoi euh
l'agroclimatologue, est-ce qu'il a un
point de vue sur les produits
phytosanitaires ? Alors non, je suis
très loin des industries des produits
phytosanitaires. C'est pas forcément
d'ailleurs mon rôle d'en parler parce
que c'est plus de la chimie et de
l'écologie. Donc ça a rien à voir avec
l'agroclimatologie. Le seul lien qu'il y
a avec mon travail, c'est par rapport au
déserbant puisque en réalité
euh l'agriculture de conservation des
sols, l'agriculture qu'on a discuté tout
au début, quand on a un couvert
intermédiaire, donc entre deux cultures
A et B, on fait un couvert pour faire de
l'ombrage, pour stocker du carbone, pour
éviter que le sol s'échauffe et pour
fertiliser ce sol, cette culture là, à
un moment, il faut la détruire. Enfin,
c'est cette cette planteel là, il faut
la détruire pour planter la plante B
qu'on va récolter. Et pour la détruire,
en général, on utilise le glyphosate, ce
fameux déserbant ou alors mécaniquement
avec du glyphosate. Mais le glyphosate
est une pièce angulaire pour cette
agriculture. Et paradoxalement,
cette agriculture a une vie dans le sol
et c'est très chiffré, beaucoup plus
importante que sur un sol bio, un sol
conventionnel. Elle stock du carbone,
elle est très bonne pour l'eau, mais
elle a l'aspect d'avoir ce fameux
glyphosate. Et là, je vais vous dire
quelque chose,
c'est qu'il n'existe pas dans aucun
système, il n'existe une agriculture
parfaite. Dans le système conventionnel,
on a des impacts sur le sol, on a des
impacts sur la biodiversité qu'on essaie
maintenant d'atténuer. Pas assez
rapidement à mon goût, mais au moins, on
essaie de les atténuer. Ceci dit,
l'aspect positif, c'est qu'on produit
beaucoup. Dans l'aspect biologique, on a
quand même l'autorisation de produits
phytosanitaires qui ne sont pas de
synthèse.
Ceux qui sont de synthèse, ils sont
interdits. On n pas forcément des
pratiques qui sont excellentes pour le
sol comme l'agriculture de conservation
des sols, mais la vie est quand même
présente dans le sol de l'agriculture
biologique. Et on a cependant une
production qui est un petit peu moins
bonne que le conventionnel. Dans
l'agroforesterie par exemple, c'est
quand on cultive des arbres ou qu'on a
des arbres et en dessous on a des
cultures. Le rendement est largement
pour l'instant inférieur dans ce cas-là
parce qu'il y a de l'ombrage de la part
des armes. Mais par contre, on stock du
carbone, on maîtrise mieux
l'environnement, l'écosystème, les
oiseaux, les insectes. Dans
l'agriculture de conservation des sols,
on maîtrise mieux notre sol. on stock
plus d'eau, on stock plus de carbone, on
a moins d'un tr aussi d'engrais parce
que c'est le sol qui qui a ce rôle de
fertiliser la plante et on a les
insectes qui se se limitent entre eux,
on va dire. Par contre, on a cet
désavantage qui est le les produits
déserbants. Donc, il n'existe pas en
réalité d'agriculture qui soit parfaite,
qui produise parfaitement bien en
respectant parfaitement le sol,
parfaitement la production agricole. Ça
n'existe pas. Donc il faut faire des
c'est un compromis l'agriculture et donc
on a ce malheur par contre en
agriculture de conservation des sales
d'avoir ce glyphosate et il faut trouver
des solutions pour le contourner. Tu
dis glyphosate nous on dit des herbants
parce que il y a d'autres
Oui, il y a d'autres il y a d'autres
désherbants. Bon après le glyphosate
c'est quelque chose qui est très
politisé en ce moment c'est pour ça que
j'en parle. C'est un terme qu'on qu'on
retrouve beaucoup dans la presse en ce
moment. Donc il y a il faut trouver des
alternatives euh notamment par rapport
euh un désherbage mécanique. La
problématique c'est que si c'est pas
assez efficace ou assez rentable parce
que l'agriculteur il doit aussi vivre et
d'ailleurs faire face au changement
climatique c'est pas basé uniquement le
le revenu sur la production. On pourra
peut-être en toucher un mot après. Et
bien
prendre soin de ces agriculteurs.
Vraiment prendre soin. Il y en a
tellement qui se suicident. Il y en a
tellement qui vivent avec un salaire qui
est l'équivalent de en dessous du seuil
de pauvreté.
Euh et la transmission des
exploitations, c'est un cauchemar. C'est
c'est c'est absolument dramatique.
Et et pour en revenir à ça, donc il
n'existe pas d'agriculture parfaite.
Donc donc je suis ni pour ni contre le
glyphosate ou l'introduction de nouveaux
herbicides ou la prolongation parce que
c'est pas mon rôle et j'ai même pas lu
une seule étude à ce sujet. Mais tout ce
que je sais, c'est que dans les
différents types d'agriculture, celles
qui protègent le sol, celles qui
protègent le climat, il y a toujours un
défaut et il y a des qualités. Le but
c'est juste de d'avoir plus de qualité
que de défaut. Voilà.
Alors, agroclimatologue, forcément, tu
as étudié euh on parlera de la pâque
après. D'accord. Si ça t'intéresse,
c'est Je me connais pas trop mais on
verra les questions.
On verra tes questions. Et euh revenons
revenons agri
agroclimatologie.
Tu as étudié les Mayas, l'histoire de
production agricole des Mayas, comment
ils sont cassés la figure, pourquoi ils
sont cassés la figure, la gestion des
points d'eau, la gestion de la
déforestation pour aller faire de la
chaud, pour aller tartiner sur leur leur
pyramide.
Est-ce que tu as étudié des
civilisations
forcément anciennes
leur façon d'anticiper,
comment le climat a influencé leur
déploiement, leur développement, leur
culture, leurs traditions, leur art
culinaire.
Quelle civilisation tu as les
Mesopotamiens ? J'ai pas étudié
l'histoire de l'agriculture donc je je
pourrais pas répondre à l'histoire du
climat. J'ai j'ai étudié je con pas
connecté. Tu as pas connecté les
cultures ?
J'ai pas forcément connecté. Non, j'ai
pas encore tout fait dans ma vie. Je
pense que tu avais l'air même plus en
avance que moi à ce sujet. Par contre,
il y a un régime que j'étudie, c'est
plus actuel que passé, c'est le régime
crétois. Parce que pour moi, le régime
crétoi, le régime méditerran le régime
libanais euh il est très proche en fait
de cette espèce d'équilibre qu'on essaie
de trouver sur enfin à l'origine
maintenant il a été un petit peu
déformé,
dévoyé. dévoyé et ben il est très proche
en fait de ce que je considère comme un
régime à l'équilibre par rapport aux
émissions de gaz à effet de serre que
fait l'agriculture également parce qu'on
consomme moins de viande rouge, on a
plus d'œuf, plus de fromage de chèvre,
beaucoup plus de légumes et de
légumineuse, le hou est un exemple
parfait, le haricot également et donc en
fait on n plus cette on n pas eu cette
évolution en Grèce. Bon, maintenant on
l'a de plus en plus mais entre pâte riz
viande qui est vraiment qui commence à
devenir voà c'est plutôt pâéie quoi.
Pas terri.
Ouais, pas terri. C'estàd que avec le
pognon qui manque la crise, l'inflation
la viande toublie peut-être. Mais
peut-être si on se passe d'il y a 5 ans,
c'est pâtes riz viande euh de moins en
moins de légumes et surtout de moins en
moins de légumes secs, le pois chiche,
le haricot. Oui, en fait, il faut
rééquilibrer ça parce que faire face au
changement climatique, c'est pas
seulement que les agriculteurs doivent
faire des efforts, c'est aussi que les
consommateurs doivent évoluer leur façon
de consommer, leur façon de consommer la
viande, leur façon de consommer les
légumineuses, de les réintroduire dans
leur alimentation. Et moi, j'aime bien
le régime créatoire. Tu parlais de
d'étude des différents régimes des
civilisations, tout ce qui est
Moyen-Orient et Grèce et Turquie. J'aime
bien ce régime là, ne serait-ce que le
comprendre pour pour son son impact sur
le climat.
Pendant que je fais du chéri dans les
questions internet, j'aimerais que tu me
parles du Liban. Tuas tu as des
connexions avec le Liban en ce moment ?
Pas du tout. Tu as des copains sur place
? Comment ça se passe ?
J'ai des connexions quand ils ont
internet, quand il y a l'électricité,
c'est-à-dire une fois une heure par
jour. Électricité une heure par jour.
Ils ont pas l'au courante. Quand je vais
au Liban en général, malheureusement
c'est pour les décès ou pour voir mes
grands-parents qui sont toujours
vivants. Donc c'est très rare que je
prenne l'avion. La seule fois où je
prends l'avion, c'est pour voir mes
grands-parents quand il y a des
problèmes de maladie. Je considère quand
même que j'ai le je je je peux aller au
Liban pour pour voir ma famille. En
France, j'ai que mes parents, mon frère
et quelques cousins et le 90 % de ma
famille est au Liban.
Ta femme est libanaise ?
Non. Elle est alssienne.
C'est peut-être pire.
Je suis pas sûr mon pote.
C'est pas du tout le même régime
alimentaire si on se base sur le régime
alimentaire. Petit clin d' Je t'ai
appris quand même.
Ah oui bien sûr. Oui, c'est non je
le foie gras.
Oui, le foie gras aussi. Bah les les
traditions françaises, je les connais
peut-être même beaucoup plus que les
traditions libanaises. Ça fait quand
même je suis arrivé en France, j'avais 2
ans. Donc pour moi, j'ai grandi en
France. Génétiquement, on va dire que je
suis libanais.
Oui, donc j'y retourne régulièrement.
Je rassure, le Liban c'est un coup de
France pour nous les Français. Les
Libans sont nos frères, les Libanais
sont nos frères.
Je suis ravi de l'entendre. Et bien en
en réalité quand je retourne au Liban,
c'est un peu déroutant pour moi euh
puisque ce mon travail moi consiste à
faire comprendre aussi au consommateurs
qu'il faut manger moins de viande, la
manger mieux, la manger française, voilà
même si elle coûte plus cher française,
la manger locale au fourrage, sur le
brac et cetera ou alors devenir
cro.
Ouais. Oui, exactement. Ou alors devenir
végétarien, le le régime qui met le
moins de gaz à effet de serre. Mais euh
c'est le choix de chacun. C'est pas à
moi de dire il faut devenir végétarien
ou il faut continuer à manger la viande.
Je considère que c'est un choix à chacun
de le faire. Alors quand je vais au
Liban, je leur dis moi je travaille sur
euh bah voilà de faire comprendre qu'il
faut limiter les gaz à effet de serre,
il faut manger moins de viande, il faut
réintroduire des légumineuses. On essaie
de faire un petit peu plus attention à
notre sol et ils me regardent, ils me
disent
"Tu as fumé du crac, il y a des
pouvelles partout. une corruption de
dingue. On est obligé d'aller au marché
noir pour changer nos dollars. Euh c'est
ça, ils disent
"Non, mais il m'a regardé mon cousin, il
m'a dit "Mais en fait, tu as tellement
d'argent que tu peux choisir ce que tu
manges. Nous, quand on gagne 10 € de
plus, on achète un bout de viande parce
qu'on peut l'acheter." Toi, tu as
tellement le choix que tu es capable de
dire "Aujourd'hui, je vais faire
l'effort de pas manger de viande." Et
là, je me suis senti con. Je me suis
senti con parce que je savais pas quoi
lui dire. Je savais pas quoi lui dire.
Moi je disais bah c'est mon cœur de
métier. Et là j'ai compris qu'en fait
nous on était dans une écologie qui
était certes avancée par rapport au
Liban. Ils ont même pas de ils savent
même pas où prendre les poubelles. Ils
ont même pas d'eau et ils ont même pas
d'électricité. Donc avant de leur dire
faites gaffe au changement climatique,
faites gaffe à votre consommation de
viande, ben j'ai envie de dire bah
manger en fait. Enfin c'est votre
premier
survivez.
Essayer d'éviter la guerre et essayer de
trouver un boulot et survivez. Et c'est
là où ça m'a un peu remis en question.
J'ai pris une claque en fait. Je me suis
dit "Bah ouais en fait,
bah ouais, tes cousins au Liban, il
voudraient bien manger plus de viande et
toi tu es en train de leur dire que tu
manques que tu mange un peu plus de
légumineuse pour manger un petit peu
moins de viande alors que tu peux te le
permettre."
C'est vrai que ça remet en question et
ça remet en question beaucoup de choses
aussi par rapport à sa perception de son
boulot, par rapport à ce que je dis
aussi euh que ce qu'en France on a des
catégories sociales qui ne peuvent pas
manger suffisamment de gens qui en ont
aussi à la cantine et ça remet un petit
peu en perspective ça un peu chamboulé
mon cerveau en me disant ouais bah le
régime végétarien à la cantine c'est
peut-être que qu' y a certaines
catégories de population qui on n'ont
pas qui ont pas forcément accès à la à
la viande tous les jours et j'aimerais
bien qu'ils en aient peut-être un peu
plus axès. Bon, alors c'est pas la
majorité de la population française et
que bien sûr dans les cantines, il faut
réintroduire aussi des légumineuse,
moins de viande mais donner quand même
le choix à certaines aux élèves de de
pouvoir choisir la viande ou non et de
travailler aussi sur la façon de
consommer, sur la façon de cuisiner à
l'école, de de comprendre pourquoi il
faut manger moins de viande, de
comprendre pourquoi il faut manger plus
de légumineuse et d'apprendre à
cuisiner. d'apprendre à cuisiner pour
toucher la matière première agricole et
mieux considérer nos agriculteurs et ce
qu'on mange en réalité.
Ilon parlé de l'inflation au Liban ?
Quand tu rentres dans un supermarché, le
temps que tu commences tes courses et
que tu finis tes courses, en fait, il y
a plus les prix parce que
le temps le temps que tu fasses tes
courses, les prix ont changé.
Exactement. C'est une très grosse
problématique qui m'inquiète parfois
pour ma famille de savoir s'il mangent
suffisant parce que la problématique
libanaise aussi c'est qu'ils sont très
fiers d'eux qu'ils ne vont jamais dire
quand ils ont un problème et quand je
demande à mes cousins si ça va tout va
bien et je sais très bien quand je vois
les infos alors peut-être sur les infos
c'est un peu déformé parce que je vais
pas vérifier sur place tous les jours
mais oui effectivement le prix de
l'alimentation est en augmentation et je
pense qu'on peut dire aux Français
qu'ils ont la chance quand même d'avoir
la France d'avoir l'Union européenne
d'avoir des des niveaux de production
important au lieu de toujours critiquer
nos agriculteurs,
aller à l'étranger et regarder ce qu'on
mange et ce qu'on produit et la qualité
de ce qu'on mange et la qualité de ce
qu'on produit. Vous reviendrez en
France. La première chose que vous allez
faire, c'est prendre une baguette, un
Rockfort et vous dire "Je suis content
d'être en France quand même."
Tiens, on va voir. On va voir si tu sais
manger le Rockfort comme les les vrais
Français. Le Rockfort, tu le coupes ou
tu le grattes ?
J'ai peur de la réponse. Je le coupe.
Alors, j'imagine qu'il faut le gratter
si tu me poses la question.
Ah, faut le gratter le Rockfort.
Ah ouais, non, je je le coupe. Bon, je
je fais peut-être pas les choses
parfaitement bien.
Non, mais t'inquiète, il y a énormément
de Français qui savent pas.
D'ailleurs, je ne comprends pas pourquoi
il y a pas eu de pédagogie des des
des producteurs
des producteurs de Rockfort pour
expliquer que le Rockfort ça se gratte.
Écoutez, prochain spot publicitaire à
Rockfort. On gratte le Rockfort.
Appelez-nous, appelez-nous. On a des
idées de dingue.
Est-ce que tu as envie de parler d'un
sujet
qu'on a pas abordé et un sujet qui te
tient à cœur ? On
n pas parlé des forêts, on n pas parlé
de la floraison. Fais-toi plaisir
parce qu'en réalité, je reprends la
question que m'a posé la première
question que m'a posé l'internaute sur
il a eu une floraison en plein m de
l'automne. Et ça c'est symptomatique de
l'évolution des rythmes saisonniers avec
le changement climatique. C'està-dire
qu'on a des arbres qui sont de plus en
plus perdus. Quand je dis arbres, c'est
la forêt, c'est également
l'agroforesterie, c'est également les
fruits, c'est également la vigne. Bon,
la vigne n'est pas un arbre, c'est une
liane mais se elle peut se comporter
pareil. Euh et bien euh quand on a euh
des arbres qui sont à la fois soumis à
des stress en avril, à des sécheresses,
puis après à des canicules qui perdent
leurs feuilles en été, qui reprennent
des feuilles en automne, qui a des
fleurs qui gèent en automne, ils sont
complètement déboussolés. Et ben en
fait, c'est que comme un être vivant, il
perd de l'énergie, peu à peu, il se
fatigue. Et ce qu'on a observé ces
dernières années, c'est extrêmement
important que j'en parle parce qu'on en
parle pas suffisamment dans les médias,
ces cinq dernières années dans les
forêts, on a des mortalités qui sont
incroyables. On a des êtres qui meurent,
on a des épicéas qui meurent. Alors, on
va me dire c'est des maladies. Mais ces
maladies, elles s'attaquent à des arbres
qui sont affaiblies par des sécheresses
au préalable. Et donc, en réalité, on en
parle pas suffisamment. Il faut
absolument parler de cette régénération,
même pas régénération en fait, de cette
mortalité de nos forêts qui après plus
tard seront remplacé par des espèce plus
au sud. C'est l'homme qui doit
intervenir à ce niveau-là, même s'il y a
des discussions après entre
scientifiques à ce niveau.
Mais on nous dit que la forêt, la France
reverdique a de plus en plus de surfaces
forestières. Mais en réalité, il faut
regarder aussi l'état de cette surface
forestière de voir qu'on a de la
mortalité des arbres. Et ça c'est
symptomatique de l'évolution des
biogéographies des arbres, de l'airire
de répartition des arbres. Peu à peu, on
en sort et ces arbres sont sans stress,
se font attaquer par des maladies et on
a des morts d'écosystème. Ça, je voulais
le dire, ça fait partie de la question
de la floraison en automne. Et cette
floraison, chaque fleur qui sortira de
son bourgeon, c'est un fruit en moins
pour l'an prochain. Donc, c'est des
paires de rendement.
Un autre sujet que tu souhaites aborder
?
la viande peut-être
la viande parce que c'est le sujet très
très chaud euh qu'on a souvent en
agriculture sur l'impact de la viande.
Et pour être franc et factuel, la viande
c'est 49 % 51 % je me rappelle plus mais
ceci dit on va dire 50 % c'est la moitié
des gazs à effet de serre de l'assiette.
Et je tiens à préciser que c'est pas
seulement c'est pas les P des vaches, ce
sont les ROS déjà pour apprendre quelque
chose, ce sont les RES des vaches qui
émettent le méthane. C'est là où il y a
la fermentation, c'est dans leur leur
leur équivalent d'estomac, on va dire.
C'est là où il rumine.
C'est là où il ruminent. Et bien euh on
me dit souvent euh en si je prends ma
casquette ou mon chapeau de
climatologue, on me dit il faut réduire
les émissions de gaz à effet de serre de
l'agriculture. Donc on va diviser par
trois la quantité de viande.
Effectivement, il faut diviser par trois
les émissions de viande parce qu'on
mange trop de viande rouge notamment. Si
on prend les nutritionnistes, ils vont
nous dire "On mange trop de viande, on
en a pas suffisamment besoin, il faut
réduire." Euh après, certains
nutritionnistes vous diront, on peut
devenir végan ou pas, la majorité vous
diront que que c'est compliqué quand
même d'être végan.
Ou alors euh ou alors euh on a
l'agroclimatologue qui va essayer de
coupler quand même ses connaissances. Et
la viande, elle sert à quoi ? la
production de viande notamment dans les
zones humidines, dans les alpages, dans
les bocages, il y a beaucoup de
diversité dans ces endroits-là, des
prairies qui stockent du carbone. C'est
très important de garder de la
production animale sur ces terroirs pour
éviter de les retourner pour faire des
grandes cultures, par exemple du maïs,
duplé.
La viande aussi, ça permet d'avoir de la
fertilisation pour le bio parce que le
bio, on peut pas utiliser des produits
de synthèse. On utilise des produits
notamment issus des animaux pour
fertiliser le sol.
Et donc la viande a un rôle essentiel
dans la production végétale. Il faut
trouver un équilibre en fait entre ce
rôle essentiel et cette surconsommation
de la viande. Il faut diminuer la viande
mais il faut pas non plus qu'on devienne
100 % végétarien. Alors il y a deux
solutions. Soit on devient végétarien.
Je considère que c'est un choix qui
peut-être louable par rapport aux
émissions de gaz à effet de serre.
Ou soit dans tous les cas, on peut pas
continuer à manger la même quantité de
viande ou soit on essaie de diminuer
notre viande, donc il faut diminuer la
viande rouge. Donc on peut manger de la
viande blanche ou du fromage ou des
œufs. Ou soit on achète cette viande
française. C'est pas pour faire
l'apologie de la la viande française.
C'est
il y a intérêt.
Il y a intérêt. Oui. Mais enfin c'est un
peu pour ça quand même. La viande
française quand même.
Oui mais en fait c'est que la viande
française en majorité elle est nourrie
au fourage. la prairie, la prairie stock
du carbone. Et donc pour réduire notre
impact de viande rouge, si on ne veut
pas devenir végétarien, je ne dis à
personne, je n'oublige rien à personne,
si on ne veut pas devenir végétarien,
acheter français, ça coûtera peut-être
plus cher, de l'RACAC, de la limousine,
acheter français et puis bah ce sera des
viandes de qualité qui auront peut-être
produit un petit peu moins de méthane au
fourge mais qui en ont reproduit, il
faut être conscient et manger au moins
manger au moins manger une fois par
jour. Une fois par jour, je commence à
fatiguer. Manger une fois par semaine de
la viande rouge, c'est suffisant. Au
lieu d'en manger trois fois quand on en
mange en moyenne de qualité française.
Voilà, soit devenir végétarien, mais
dans tous les cas, il faut diminuer la
viande rouge. Si vous voulez continuer à
manger la la viande rouge, mangez-la
française.
Alors, je vais je vais essayer de te
déconcentrer un peu plus. Donc, on est
au début de notre interview.
Ah bah, dis donc, là pour toute la nuit.
Euh ouais et on a des menottes et en
fouet, tu vas pas pouvoir partir.
Nous on a des petits indices, des
petites sondes. Alors je On a par
exemple le les prévisions d'achat de
graisse pour les machines outil. On a
l'indice Big Mac H.
Et je vois que tu collectionnes
des boîtes de McDonald's.
Tu es en train de me dire c'est quand
qu' vont me dire vos vient de me
l'envoyer. Donc tu collectionnes 53 pays
de différents
51. Alors la dépêche fake news. Donc
laadpêche.fr le collectionneur fou de
900 pièces de 53 pays différents. Donc
tu collectionnes les boîtes de
McDonald's.
Je suis le plus grand collectionneur de
boîtes de McDo du monde. Alors ça paraît
vachement étonnant par rapport à mon
boulot
mais en réalité j'aime bien un petit peu
jouer sur cette c'est un peu ce décalage
un peu cette cette folie de
collectionner et puis cette bipolarité
chez le le personnage que j'essaie
d'entretenir. En réalité.
Pourquoi tuentretiens un personnage
d'ailleurs ? parce que j'aime bien ça,
c'est tout. En réalité euh la collection
de Mat Mcdo, j'aime bien mettre en avant
un peu l'aspect débile de cette
collection, mais il y a vraiment quelque
chose de beaucoup plus intelligent
derrière puis qu'en réalité McDonald's
est une entreprise mondialisée, vous le
savez très bien, c'est l'une des plus
grandes entreprises du monde.
C'est pour ça qu'il y a l'indice Big
Mac,
c'est ça, il y a l'indice Big Mac qui
regarde le prix par rapport à
l'inflation, il me semble, ou le prix ou
le PIB, je je sais pas trop.
Et pour chaque pour investir chaque
pays, McDonald's a compris qu'il fallait
s'adapter à l'agroalimentaire et à
l'agriculture de chaque pays.
C'est-à-dire que pour vendre plus de Big
Mac en France de de burger, il faut
faire un petit charolet, il faut faire
un truc au compté, il faut faire un
macracle, il faut que tu es l'impression
de manger français dans un dans la plus
grosse industrie du monde de burger
américain quoi. Et ce qui m'intéresse
moi, c'est pas l'apologie du Big Mac ou
l'apologie de McDonald's, c'est de voir
comment avec l'agroalimentaire et le
marketing, on arrive à te faire croire
que tu manges français un burger
français dans la plus grosse,
on va dire francisé.
Francisé en fait, il s'adapte à chaque
pays.
C'est quand même une bonne stratégie.
Alors, c'est une bonne stratégie si on
est du côté de McDonald's, on regarde si
c'est une bonne stratégie. du côté de
McDonald's ou ailleurs, on note les
résultats.
Alors, le résultat c'est que McDonald's
achète français, le blé, les patates, la
viande. Alors, il y a peut-être quelques
nuances à apporter parce que j'ai pas
tout vérifié hein, mais il y a des
tissus économiques qui se forment avec
les agriculteurs. Je me suis dit, je
suis pas là pour faire la publicité pour
McDonald's. Mais c'est que dans cette
dans dans cette en fait dans cette
collection, en te promenant dans cette
collection, en la regardant, tu peux
voir la stratégie de McDonald's dans
chaque pays du monde. Comment ils ont
fait pour franciser mais américaniser,
canadieniser, espagnoliser, italieniser,
je sais pas les burgers. Et moi, je
trouve ça vachement intéressant comment
une entreprise mondialisée est en fait
une des petites entités qui sont par
pays. Et donc alors ça paraît parfois
vachement étonnant que je fais cette
collection, mais derrière cela euh mon
but est vraiment de comprendre aussi le
marketing et comment une société société
une entreprise mondialisée arrive.
Commencé à quel âge ? Alors, c'est parti
d'un délire avec mes colocataires quand
j'étais en école d'ingénieur et puis
maintenant j'en ai 900 différentes avec
plein de recette. Je les empile.
C'est la même taille pour toutes ?
Non, c'est pas la même taille pour
toutes. Donc j'ai des cartons avec des
tailles différentes.
Comment tu les reçois ? Tu as été faire
51. Alors au début, j'avais pas mal de
colloques de colloques c'estàdire
scientifiques euh où j'allais à
l'étranger pour donc je prenais les
poites. Étant chasseur d'orage aussi,
parfois il m'arrive d'aller en Espagne,
en Italie, c'est pas très loin de
Montpellier, je récupère ces boîtes et
puis après avec une certaine
médiatisation il y a 10 ans euh les gens
m'ont envoyé par la poste.
Pourquoi tuappelles pas McDonald's
directement ?
Ils m'ont déjà appelé.
C'est vrai,
ils m'ont déjà appelé. Et d'ailleurs, il
y a une exposition qu'on va faire sur le
marketing McDonald's pour les 20 ans de
Alors, je ne fais pas la publicité de du
fast food, c'est très très loin de mes
convictions. Euh, on va faire on va
essayer de comprendre comment McDonald's
s'est inséré dans chaque pays pour pour
vendre en fait ces burgers. Et en
réalité, c'est presque une étude
socio-économique hyper intéressante. Ça
a l'air débile comme ça et surtout
antagoniste par rapport à mon travail.
Il faut pas dire débile, il faut pas
tomber tomber.
Moi, j'aime bien dire débile. C'est mon
mot. Enfin, il y a des mots comme ça que
je que j'aime bien dire. Alors, ça a
l'air
simple, je sais pas comment dire, ça a
l'air antagoniste par rapport à ce que
je fais de la vie de tous les jours.
Mais en réalité derrière, j'essaie de
comprendre comment c'est. Par exemple,
Burger King ou ce bois, il s'adapte pas
forcément autant que McDonald's à la
culture de chaque pays,
mais de façon quick, ils ont pas besoin
de s'adapter. Ils ont le quick and
toast.
Le quick
c'est belge mais ils se sont pas du tout
adaptés. Si il y a peut-être les
montagnards ou les trucs dans ce genre,
ils ont copié McDonald's. Mais
ceci dit euh il y a quand même un aspect
intéressant derrière tout ça qui émane
de la collection.
Alors question internet
donc avec un petit peu de latence. Hm
hm.
Question
côté climatoceptique. Hm
hm.
Le climatosceptique ne reg attends le
climatosceptique ne regarde pas plus
loin que 2015. Est-ce que les experts
scientifiques médiatisés regardent
au-delà de 1880 ? Car les cycles du
soleil font varier les températures
moyennes sur Terre depuis la nuit des
temps ? Non. Point d'interrogation.
Qu'est-ce que tu peux répondre à ça ?
Il y a une différence. Il y a toujours
eu des variations de climat dans le
monde sur Terre. Il y a toujours eu des
variations naturelles du climat. Il y a
une différence entre l'évolution qu'on a
actuellement qui est extrêmement rapide,
induite par l'homme
avec une grande vélocité.
Avec une grande vélocité, les les
écosystèmes n'ont même pas le temps de
remonter vers le nord pour s'adapter.
Euh et on a une différence avec les
cycles astronomiques qu'on avait avant
euh glaciation, air interglaciaire,
enfin et cetera.
C'est différent. ces différences dans la
vitesse d'arrivée de ce changement
climatique et pardon et ça c'est très
important pour un agroclimatologue parce
que si on était sur un cycle climatique
habituel où on a de longues variations,
bah je peux vous dire qu'on a le temps
de faire monter nos pommiers, les
enlever d'Espagne et les faire monter à
Oslo. On a le temps
euh Non mais on les plante
progressivement. On a le temps de faire
monter nos oliviers du côté du Danemark.
que on a le temps de faire évoluer notre
maïs. Là, les écosystèmes n'ont même pas
le temps de se régénérer. On a des
mortalités forestières. Ça montre bien
qu' a un moment on est beaucoup plus
rapide que ce qu'on avait avant. Et
quand on remonte même plus loin que
1880, pour le monsieur qui me pose la
question sur 1880, je peux remonter dans
la date de floraison comme je disais
pour le suris japonais, c'est 871.
C'est c'est beaucoup plus loin que 1880.
Et là, on voit bien les variations
climatiques et le décrochage qui n'a
rien à voir avec un cycle. Et et pour
moi, c'est important de distinguer cette
vitesse. C'est cette vitesse en fait qui
est un problématique parce que la Terre
a le temps de s'adapter aux variations
climatiques naturelles, sauf météorite
et volcans trop violent. OK, les volcans
ça dure quelques années. Les météorites,
là ça peut faire de de gros problèmes au
niveau de la terre. On les dinosaures
s'en souviennent.
Par contre, les changements climatiques
naturels autres dû à des aspects de de
la Terre, du soleil ou à d'autres
aspects oublier la bombe nucléaire
làdedans entre les dinosaures.
Alors la bombe nucléaire, je pense pas
qu'elle est fait d'évolution climatique
pour l'instant d'accord avec toi.
Mais j'espère pas que ça va être le cas
parce que j'aimerais pas ça va faire
l'équivalent d'un volcan.
Voilà. Euh don donc oui, il faut
comprendre que c'est la vitesse qui est
problématique, que c'est pas le
changement en lui-même, c'est le la
vitesse de ce changement qui est
problématique.
Question internet. Hm hm.
Toujours dans la même euh dans le du
même bois.
Hm hm.
Un scientifique entre guillemets
qui ne discute pas et reste sur ses
certitudes est-il toujours un
scientifique ? Point d'interrogation.
Alors, il y en a quatre points
d'interrogation. On sent une une envie
de réponse.
Une envie de réponse. J'ai discuté avec
les climatosceptiques. J'ai discuté il y
a 3 ans. J'ai commencé à discuter avec
eux. Il y a un moment, c'est facile de
mettre une petite question là sur
internet et de dire un scientifique
entre guillemets, venez faire mon
travail à ma place. Venez voir en fait
ce que c'est que discuter avec un climat
sceptique et de perdre votre temps à
essayer de convaincre une personne.
Faites-le à ma place. Et vous verrez, il
y a un moment vous allez vous dire "Bon
ben, j'avance. Si j'ai l'occasion de
discuter avec eux une autre fois, je
vais essayer. Si je vois qu'ils sont
butés sur leurs arguments, je ne vais
pas essayer. Donc c'est bien gentil à ce
messieur de mettre des des entre
guillemets sur le terme scientifique,
mais un scientifique comme moi qui
essaie quand même de discuter avec les
climats soci qui a essayé, je pense pas
que ce soit bienvenu de dire ça.
Et quand tu discutes, tu bois des canons
ou tu bois pas des canons ?
Bah non, parce qu'ils veulent rester
anonymes. Je ne sais même pas avec qui
je discute en réalité. Je ne sais même
pas à quoi ressemblent ces personnes.
Ils viennent m'agresser sur Twitter.
Alors, j'ai il y a des fois où j'essaie
de faire un peu d'humour ou d'apporter
un peu d'arguments, mais quand on
manipule les données climatiques, quand
on on prend une cette année au lieu de
prendre un siècle et demi,
je suis désolé faire un uler de l'om
quand on prend 7 années au lieu de un
siècle et demi pour me dire qu'il y a un
refroidissement climatique.
Ouais, c'est vachement engageant pour un
scientifique comme moi d'aller parler à
des personnes qui en fait commencent à
manipuler les données qui ont des
intérêts derrière et qui de toute façon
ne vont pas t'écouter puisque ils ont
des intérêts. Et peut-être que ces
intérêts, je ne vois pas les connaître.
On ne suputera pas des intérêts.
Question internet. Pense-t-il qu'il est
utopique voire inutile d'envisager une
production agricole tournée vers la
permaculture à l'échelle nationale ?
Alors, la permaculture, ça demande de la
main d'œuvre. Donc l'utopie ne va pas
venir de moi, mais l'utopie va venir en
fait des gensquivalent sont prêts à
sortir de la ville et à retourner à la
campagne. Déjà premier point
pour 600 balles par mois,
c'est ça ? Et pour se casser le dos
aussi. Euh même si maintenant il y a des
techniques peut-être un petit peu plus
modernes.
Les exosquelettes, non ?
Je sais pas si c'est le cas, mais ça
peut être intéressant aussi à explorer.
Je sais pas, le numérique reste toujours
intéressant à explorer pour faire face
au changement climatique. Il faut garder
toutes les solutions. Euh autre point,
la permaculture, elle elle a quand même
des rendements qui sont largement
inférieurs. Par contre, elle a des
aspects extrêmement intéressants sur le
sol, sur la diversité de production et
sur l'environnement. Et sur les valeurs
nutritives ?
Alors sur les valeurs nutritives, dans
les articles que j'ai lu, on peut me
contredire.
C'est c'est
euh il n'y aura pas forcément de
différence de valeur nutritive entre une
tomate en plein champ et une tomate en
en permaculture, on va dire.
Et en terme de goût,
par contre, le goût aussi, pareil dans
les articles que j'ai lu et on peut me
contredire, n'hésitez pas. Le goût, il
joue sur la distance entre le lieu de
production et le lieu de consommation.
Donc la réfrigération, les variations de
température peuvent altérer le goût. Le
temps entre le lieu de cueillette et le
lieu de vente. Le le goût s'altère au
fil du temps dans le légume. Les
conditions de sol également et les
conditions aussi d'ensoleillement. Et la
variété principalement, c'est la variété
qui font les variations de goût. Par
contre, si tu as une tomate en
permaculture de la même variété dans un
sol conventionnel ou euh non, peut-être
pas le sol, mais euh sur la même
parcelle avec des pesticides sans
pesticides, tu auras le même goût. C'est
pas les pesticides qui vont faire la
différence. C'est vraiment queen
permaculture, on a plus tendance à
vendre en circuit local et donc il n'y a
pas de réfrigération et variation de
température et ce qui fait que ces ces
ces aspectsl ont plus de goût. Donc
acheter local, c'est aussi avoir la
garantie d'avoir plus de goût.
Alors là, je vais te poser une question
un peu révolutionnaire.
Zaka
oui
avec l'autoroute à 69
on comprend que les actions législative
[Musique]
légalistes pardon plus près l'écran que
les actions légalistes et pacifistes
sont inoffensives même des gens peuvent
mourir. Est-ce que la seule solution ne
serait pas de lancer une guerre
écologique totale contre la civilisation
industrielle ? Et là, je sais pas et je
vous avoue, j'ai presque envie de vous
poser la question parce que je n'ai
aucune réponse vraiment à apporter. Je
n'ai pas réfléchi euh à cette réponse et
je me pose toujours ces questions.
Est-ce qu'il faut un petit peu sortir
des lois pour euh bah montrer qu'il y a
un problème ? Est-ce qu'il faut rester
dans la je je sais pas je sais pas
quelle est euh la solution. Je sais
qu'il y a une plité de solution pour
faire face au changement climatique pour
parler aussi de l'environnement. Moi,
j'ai pris la solution média pédagogie
sur les réseaux sociaux. Certains ont
pris la solution de bloquer un périf,
même si à terme euh je pense que ça peut
agacer les gens et être contreproductif
euh même si ça part d'une bonne idée à
l'origine. Euh attention à ne pas trop
dégrader les œuvres d'art parce que
parfois j'ai vu des trucs enfin les
œuvres d'art nous ont rien fait. Euh
mais ceci dit ça fait parler dans les
médias.
Je sais pas en fait s'il faut c'est
c'est des questions que je me pose.
Alors par contre moi personnellement ça
me fait mal au cœur quand des des
personnes écolo ou des personnes avec
des convictions climatiques vont
dégrader des choses les agriculteurs
parce que les agriculteurs, ils sont
aussi dans dans
enfin ils ont pas besoin de ça, ils ont
déjà beaucoup de pression et pour moi
ils doivent être soutenu vraiment par
pour refaire le dialogue, il faut qu'il
soit soutenu par la civilisation enfin
par la société
au lieu d'envoyer de détruire des bâches
ou de ou de de de détruire des cultures,
je pour moi là ça me fait mal au cœur
parce que c'est quand même mon domaine
et j'ai vu des choses sur internet qui
m'ont fait mal au cœur. Voilà et je
pense pas que c'est des choses qui ont
fait avancer le débat en terme de de
construction de d' dialogue en fait
entre les scientifiques, entre
l'écologie et les agriculteurs. Ça les a
plus braqué. Je peux vous dire que ça
leur a fait du mal en fait, même si sur
les plateaux télé, on a tendance à
monter un peu la voix, mais en fait ça
leur fait du mal et je pense pas que ce
soit la la bonne solution de détruire
des des choses sans sans sans avoir pris
peut-être l'initiative de parler. Je
sais pas si dans toutes les actions on a
parlé à fin.
Tu as déjà conduit une moissonneuse
batteuse avec un rateau de 7 m ? Non,
j'ai déjà conduit euh des tracteurs.
Bon, ça m'amuse. J'aime bien aussi euh
les tracteurs, mais j'en reste plus
passionné à distance que de conduire une
moissonneuse batteuse.
J'étais dedans
dans la moissonneuse quand euh
avec ou sans GPS.
Alors, il y a des GPS maintenant et ça
peut être extrêmement intéressant.
D'ailleurs, les agriculteurs se font
braquer euh par des des
de la délinquence des pays de l'Est pour
aller revendre ça sur
Exactement. Et j'étais d'ailleurs en
Bourgogne ce matin et un concessionnaire
s'est fait voler tous les GPS et les
pièces un peu technologiques qu'on qu'on
ajoute dans les tracteur et certainement
il il n'est plus d'après le
concessionnaire en France. Euh
et on arrive pas à tracer les GPS en
étant des trac GPS. Non, je demandé mais
est-ce que est-ce qu'on peut retrouver
ces non ces pièces là ? Non,
malheureusement. Bon, c'est comme ça.
Euh alors, parfois c'est marrant cette
question sur le GPS parce que ça ça
introduit un petit peu l'agriculture de
précision, l'agriculture numérique.
Parfois, ça fait un peu peur mais je
pense qu'il y a quand même tout à
prendre pour faire face au changement
climatique. Il y a des solutions qui
sont plus rapides, des solutions moins
rapides. Mais dans l'agriculture
numérique, il y a des choses qui sont
intéressantes. Déjà, l'agroclimatologie,
c'est de l'agriculture numérique. L'air
de répartition des espèces, on utilise
les données climatiques, les modèles
agronomiques. On voit bien que
l'agriculture numérique, c'est pas juste
déshumaniser l'agriculteur et prendre
les décisions à sa place. C'est aussi
des données qui permettent de faire des
choses extrêmement intéressante. Les GPS
dans les moissonneuses batteuses, ça
permet de piloter et de voir dans
certaines localités de la parcelle qu'il
y a peut-être des rendements qui sont
inférieurs. Si on observe d'année en
année qu'il y a toujours des rendements
plus inférieurs sur le côté nord-est de
la parcelle, on va aller faire un
prélèvement de terre pour voir s'il y a
des choses à apporter. peut-être plus de
fertilisation organique, peut-être
changer le travail du sol-là de la
parcelle qui a besoin d'autres choses.
Donc il y a aussi des différences
intraparcellaires qui permettent d'être
corrigées par ces données satellitaires
qui sont reliées au rendement. Après, il
faut faire attention bien sûr que ces
données qu'on a chez l'agriculteur
n'aillent pas être vendu par d'autres
grands acteurs de la donnée. Ça c'est
une autre problématique et bien sûr il
faut faire il faut il faut y faire
attention mais il faut pas tout jeter
dans l'agriculture numérique. Bien sûr
l'intelligence artificielle qui prend
toutes les décisions à la place d'un
agriculteur sans bon sens paysan.
Ça pour l'instant et je sais pas si dans
la société d'avenir ça remplacera
le bon sens pays le bon sens paysan. Le
bon sens paysan, c'est un paysan qui
connaît ses vallons, qui sait que ces
vallons-là ont plus de gel que d'autres,
qui connaît aussi les qualités
caillouuse de son sol, qui connaît les
qualités de son sol, qui connaît les
différences d'argiles dans la sein de la
parcelle, qui connaît le vent dominant
de son territoire avec les ha et dans
quel sens il doit les placer pour couper
ce vent, éviter les vaporans qui connaît
visuellement la maturité de ses fruits
et légumes, qui connaît l'historique de
de sa parcelle, qui connaît pour les
vignerons l'historique de la
vigification tout ça pour moi c'est
l'histoire de la France bon sens paysan
donc quand on a l'un du de
l'intelligence artificielle
ça peut être utile pour améliorer les
décision peut-être faire penser des
choses qu'on avait pas pensé mais en
tout cas prendre la décision à la place
de l'agriculteur pour l'instant je pense
que c'est beaucoup trop précoce et
faites attention à ce genre de de
pratique. Alors peut-être que je suis un
petit peu vieux jeu à 34 ans. Ça me
paraît peut-être je suis peut-être un
peu dépassé par rapport à tout ça.
La COP 28 en Arabie Saoudite,
ça pousse à la défiance du grand public
pour l'interrogation. Organiser une COP
dans un pays semi-disertique, c'est
parce que ils sont très sensibilisés au
problèmes de la flotte, du réchauffement
climatique.
C'est même avant de de de de de parler
de Dubaï ou ou de du président de la
COP. Quand on fait un exercice 27 fois
et qu'on se trompe à chaque fois et que
les les émissions de gaz à effet ser
continuent à augmenter à l'école si on
fait un exercice 27 fois, on vous dit
mais vous redoublez vous changez de
classe, vous faites autre chose, bah là
on fait pour la 28e fois. Il y a un
moment, j'ai envie de dire s'il y avait
un effet sur la courbe de CO2, je dirais
bon bah voilà, continuons
euh la courbe de CO2 mondiale. Je parle
pas de les différences entre les pays,
mais là quand on regarde, il y a des
très beaux graphiques assez marrants, on
voit le CO2 qui augmente et on met les
COP 21, COP 21
et ça a pas l'air de changer
grand-chose. Donc j'ai un peu ce
désespoir que j'ai au fond de moi où je
me dis à quoi bon encore suivre cette
côte façon je ne la suis pas
enfin à quoi bon encore faire des
réunions sur le climat pour pour que le
CO2 continue d'augmenter voilà peut-être
que je suis très pessimiste et qu'on va
me critiquer sur cette réponse et que
d'autres climatologues ont été peut-être
plus optimistes.
Voilà moi je je me prononce plus sur les
cops parce que j'ai toujours été déçu.
Le côté agroclimatique,
tu t'intéresses ou
je je lis la question. Le changement
climatique ne risque-t-il pas de
perturber la circulation océanique ? Un
petit peu quand même. Non, ça c'est mon
commentaire, désolé.
Et par conséquent de priver l'Europe
occidentale de la chaleur du Golfstream,
qu'en est-il de cette éventualité ? Toi,
en tant qu' agroclimatologue, est-ce que
tu t'intéresses à ce type de de de
facteur débilitant ?
Bien sûr, de facteurs
débilitant. débilitant.
Ouais. Qui aggrave le la connerie qui
aggrave la
Je crois qu'il fallait pas dire débile.
Je me suis dit
Non mais t'inquiète, ça vient pas de la
même racine.
OK.
Euh
alors déjà attention, c'est pas le
Glfstam qui nous apporte la douceur. Le
Glstam c'est quelque chose qui va jusque
de des Caraïbes qui longe l'Amérique,
qui s'arrête vers le Grosland. Chez
nous, c'est la dérive nord-atlantique
qui nous apporte la douceur. Donc
attention au vocabulaire.
cette dérive nord-atlantique, il y a eu
un article récemment qui montrait
qu'elle était en baisse mais qu'elle
était toujours présente. Et d'ailleurs,
il n'y a pas de consensus scientifique
sur cette arrêt ou cette cette évolution
de pour l'instant de la dérive
nord-atlantique ou du Golfstream. Il n'y
a pas de consensus scientifique qui nous
fait dire qu'on aura un refroidissement
sur l'Europe, notamment en hiver. En
tout cas, c'est pas ce qu'on observe.
Nos hivers, en fait, il ils sont de plus
en plus doux. C'est pour ça d'ailleurs
qu'on a des floraisons de plus en plus
précoces. Donc on n pas encore de
consensus scientifique. Donc moi me
basant en tant qu'agroclimatologue sur
aussi les résultats des climatologues,
je n'intègre pas forcément dans mes
résultats le refroidissement de l'Europe
parce qu'il n'est pas intégré dans les
résultats forcément climatiques, du
réchauffement climatique que j'utilise
du JC ou du drias sur les réseaux
français. Donc j'intègre plutôt la le
réchauffement de l'hiver. Alors, je
garde en tête de lire comme tout
scientifique les nouveautés qui sont
avancées et la science n'est pas juste
figée éternellement. Il y a peut-être
alors il y a bien un réchauffement,
après il peut y avoir des évolutions
dans ce réchauffement là. C'est pas figé
à au cè de degrés près.
Et bien voilà, je me base vraiment sur
ces résultats là. Donc il n'y a pas de
consensus, donc je me renseigne mais je
n'intègre pas ça forcément tant qu'il
n'y a pas de consensus dans les
résultats de l'agroclimatologie. C'est
plutôt le métier des climatologie,
est-ce que c'est une faute de
Alors le problème c'est quand vous avez
un discours pluri résultat devant des
agriculteurs qui doivent prendre des
décisions.
Bah si si je suis avec des
climatologues, je peux en parler. Mais
un agriculteur tu vas lui dire "Bon bah
il y a 80 % de chance de réchauffement,
20 % de chance de refroidissement. Alors
euh tu as éventuellement le tu vas
mettre de la pistache mais peut-être que
tu vas tout perdre dans 20 ans. Non euh
ils vont plus rien comprendre. il faut
quand même aller dans une direction et
garder un consensus parce que si on
donne tous les petits détails de tous
les climatologues et ce qu'ils pensent,
on va perdre tout le monde. Donc moi,
j'essaie quand même de garder le
consensus et de parler de ça. Mais cette
question sur la dérive nord-atlantique,
on me l'a posé à toutes les conférences
tout comme les réserves de substitution
en eau, les bassines où c'est voilà, on
me pose cette question ils sont
conscients en fait eux-mêmes, ils lisent
les agriculteurs, ils sont conscients
aussi de cette éventualité qui n'est pas
un consensus, je le rappelle.
Euh
je suis en train de lire la question du
même.
Je te la lis.
Vas-y. Vas-y.
Ne savez-vous pas que les mammouths ont
disparu de la surface de la terre si
rapidement qu'il avait encore de la
nourriture dans leurs estomacs ? Ah non
mais là tu planes mec. Alors quand tu
pour le voir il est mort de quoi ? Il
est peut-être mort de maladie. Non mais
il est tombé dans un trou, il s'est fait
geler. D'accord.
Enfin bon, il y a un moment faut arrêter
de chercher des excuses pour
faut arrêter absolument de chercher
n'importe quel argument pour contrer le
changement climatique quoi. Enfin là,
c'est là c'est c'est l'exemple parfait
où tu me dis il faut que je discute avec
eux mais pour premier abord envie de
dire bah je je m'enfuis, je vais C'est
là où il faut que tu te fasses violence.
Oui,
c'est là où tu parce que tu as une
grande responsabilité
et vraiment et et que il faut à chaque
fois avec le mec calme le
Je vais me faire violence, je vais
répondre à ce monsieur en lui disant "Je
ne sais pas de quoi est mort ce
mammouth. Il est peut-être tombé dans un
trou. Il était peut-être malade, il
avait peut-être mangé avant. Comment on
peut faire le lien qu'il m'explique s'il
veut entre ce qu'il avait dans l'estomac
et qu'il est mort rapidement ? Quel est
le lien avec le climat ? Je sais pas,
peut-être analyser ce qu'il avait dans
l'estomac pour savoir quel climat il y
avait. Ça ça peut être intéressant mais
alors sa mort je ne sais pas et que d'où
est-ce qu'il a sorti ça ? Quelle est sa
source d'ailleurs de ça ? Est-ce qu'il a
un graphique, des données à partager ?
Je communiquerai avec lui. Il peut venir
me parler sur Twitter s'il veut avec
beaucoup de bienveillance comme tu le
veux.
C'est très important. Il faut toujours
être bienveillant avec tout le monde et
surtout très poli.
Est-ce que tu as trois bouquins à nous
conseiller ? Alors, ça va être très
pardon, ça va être très bizarre pour
lui.
Attends juste avant. Juste avant. Tu
connaissais la chaîne avant de venir ?
Ben bien sûr, je la connaissais.
Tu veux que je dise l'histoire de la
chaîne ? Alors moi, en tant que chasseur
d'orage, on a pas parlé de la chasse à
l'orage
parce que je photographe d'orage.
Ça sent quoi un orage ?
Ça sent rien du tout. Ah si,
ça sent le pétrichur avant l'orage
lorsque la les gouttes de pluie tombent
sur la le bitume et il y a des réactions
chimiques qui se produisent et ça dégage
une odeur qui s'appelle le pétrichaor.
On dit pas que ça sent l'ozone.
Bah c'est en fait c'est le pétrichor
mais c'est pas l'ozone. Enfin à ma
connaissance peut-être que je me trompe,
c'est le pétricheur. C'est l'odeur du
début de la pluie. Après quand quand il
pleut beaucoup, bah il y a plus cette
odeur là. Euh
voilà. Voilà. L'odeur de l'orage, c'est
le fameux pétrichor. J'espère que je
vous ai appris un un mot aujourd'hui.
Tu m'as appris un mot aujourd'hui.
Tu as vu ? Tu as vu ? Tu m'as appris des
mots aujourd'hui. Je t'en apprends
aussi. Et bien, c'était quoi la question
? C'est
est-ce que tu connais Non non. Est-ce
que tu connaissais la chaîne ? Bien sûr
que je connaissais la chaîne en fait
lorsque je chassais le orage. Il m'
arrivé régulièrement quand j'étais seul
de rentrer et d'écouter euh les podcasts
avant euh de rentrer me coucher parce
que ça me permettait de me rester
veiller, stimuler et d'apprendre des
choses euh quand je conduisais parce que
j'ai l'impression parfois de perdre mon
temps quand je conduis euh et le fait
d'apprendre des choses. Merci Syerview
de m'apprendre des choses. Alors je suis
pas toujours d'accord avec ce qui se dit
mais ceci dit une personne qui doit
avancer dans sa vie doit aussi écouter
les arguments des autres. Comme tu le
disais, pour les climatosceptiques, je
le fais quand même assez régulièrement,
malgré que tu tu as pas l'impression que
c'est ça, mais je le fais quand même
assez régulièrement.
C'est quoi un chasseur d'orage ?
Alors, un chasseur d'orage, pour faire
simple, c'est un reporteur climatique de
terrain. Lorsqu'il y a de l'orage, on a
plusieurs fonctions. Notre première
fonction pour nous, c'est de faire des
photos. On est fan des photos d'orage.
On essaie de de faire de belles photos.
D'ailleurs, une photo que j'ai prise le
4 août 2020 à Cann a été élue par un
comité de de d'artistes indépendants et
par le public, plus belle photo du monde
de météorologie. On peut la voir sur mon
site internet ou en tapant sur internet
mon nom. Une très belle photo que j'ai
faite et j'en suis particulièrement
fier. Donc le premier but c'est de faire
des photos d'orage. OK. Le 2ème but
aussi, c'est de faire des reports
d'observation. Par exemple, sur
l'association faux climat, l'association
des passionnés de météorologie et ben on
peut faire des reports d'observation de
grélon, de grê géant, de tornades,
d'inondation urbaine. Donc ça sert aussi
à confirmer une prévision. Ça sert à
météo au France, avoir des observations
de terrain. Donc ça c'est notre second
rôle un petit peu plus scientifique.
Mais le premier rôle c'est vraiment de
la photo la photo d'environnement quoi.
Au final, c'est vachement beau pour moi
un orage et je conseille à tout le monde
de regarder le sel quand il y a un orage
au lieu de se réfugier à l'intérieur.
Alors il y a
Est-ce que tu peux enlever ton chapeau
une seule seconde ?
Première fois que je fais ça face
caméra.
Beau gosse.
Ah bah j'ai des cheveux hein. Tu peux
remettre au chapeau. Il va super bien.
Merci.
Est-ce que tu as trois bouquins à
conseiller à notre communauté ?
Alors ça va être bizarre mais je ne lis
pas beaucoup. Je ne suis pas un grand
lecteur, sauf d'articles scientifiques
ou de choses sur l'agriculture.
Alors, trois films,
je ne regarde pas la télévision ni des
films au passage. Je je suis très très
très météo. Moi, je hyper spécialisé.
Alors, moi, j'ai quelque chose qui m'a
lancé dans l'agroométéorologie. C'est
pas un livre grand public, c'est un
livre scientifique. C'est le livre vert
du projet Climator qui a été écrit par
Linra.
Tu me parlais de Kaddafi d'une seule
seconde. Vas-y, continue. Kaddafi. Le le
le livre vert du projet Climator qui est
disponible sur la DEM en PDF
téléchargeable gratuitement, c'est une
overview, on va dire, une grande vision
de ce que c'est le changement climatique
et les impacts agricoles sur la vigne,
le blé, le maïs et on apprend plein de
choses. Alors, c'est pas du tout un
roman qu'on va lire, mais c'est voilà
des bases en agroclimatologie.
Euh, il y a également un livre que je
suis en train de lire qui est très
intéressant sur l'agriculture à l'heure
de l'anthropocène. Je ne sais pas si
c'est refondé l'agriculture à l'ors de
l'entropocène qui me paraît vachement
intéressant et je te conseille de le
lire parce que là, tu auras beaucoup
d'aspects sociétaux et aussi euh sur
l'évolution des sociétés par rapport à
l'agriculture et et les problèmes de
prix aussi agricole. Enfin, il y a plein
de choses à avoir les problèmes
d'environnement, il y a plein de choses
à avoir
refondé l'agriculture à l'heure de
l'entropocène de Bertrand
Bertrand Valorg,
c'est ça. Après, il y a Sébastien Abis
qui travaille également sur euh la
géopolitique du blé, je me rappelle a la
géopolitique du Suc qui est sortie il y
a pas longtemps que j'ai pas lu. La
géopolitique du blé que j'ai commencé à
toucher. C'est très rare que j'achète un
livre donc pour y arriver. Merci
Sébastien. Donc on que que j'ai commencé
à lire qui me paraît vachement
intéressant.
La géopolitique non géopolitique du blé
le produit vital pour la sécurité
mondiale.
Voilà de tu vas nous trouver son numéro
de téléphone, on va l'appeler monsieur.
Bah tout à fait, il est il fait beaucoup
de conférences comme moi et c'est
quelqu'un d'extrêmement bien pour le
monde agricole et pour la compréhension
et je pense que c'est des choses qui
t'intéressent vu les questions que tu
m'as posées.
Est-ce que tu as un conseil pour les
jeunes générations ? une bouteille à la
mer,
quelque chose d'impérissable qui restera
le temps d'une
d'un cycle solaire en temps en temps si
si nos réseaux crament pas avec une
éruption une éruption solaire.
Un conseil pour les jeunes générations.
Bon, en même temps, je veux dire des
conseils pour faire face au climat, pour
faire face au changement climatique
et le plus grand conseil, je besoin de
jeunes génération devenir agriculteur
parce qu'on a besoin d'agriculteur déjà
pour la souveraineté alimentaire. On a
besoin de la relève et il n'y a pas
assez de relève au niveau des
agriculteurs. Devenir agriculteur
apporter de nouvelles idées à
l'agriculture. Renouveler un peu ces
idées-là, ces traditions. Soyez le futur
acteur de l'abricot d'âge insec. Soyez
le futur acteur de la bière au sorgot de
Toulouse ou du biscuit de sorgot, je
sais pas. Euh mais pour ceux qui sont
intéressés par l'agriculture, hésitez
pas à vous lancer là-dedans.
Malheureusement, il y en a de moins en
moins, vu qu'on est plus en plus urbain
et on a de moins en moins de famille
dans l'agriculture. Mais
allez, euh, je sais pas, dans des
jardins partagés, vous voyez ce que
c'est, produisez et puis hésitez pas à
devenir agriculteur. Les jeunes
agriculteurs ont besoin de la relève
parce qu'on en a de moins en moins.
Allez voir Nicolas Merrieux sur la
chaîne YouTube La barbe qui est devenu
agriculteur. Bah peut-être par exemple
Serge Zaka. Merci.
Merci à vous.
[Musique]